you
yo are we live
let us know in the chat if we're live
Andrew look look awake would you
for crying out loud are you gonna say
this isn't jabby's challenge this is not
jabby don't fall asleep you can you can
sleep all you want me around the the
cine Pals Channel but not here we used
up all of our notification Bells so you
know
um please leave a like on this video
because we're not you our notification
Bell did not go out to most of our
subscribers today for this stream so be
interesting to see how many people
appear but who do we got in the chat so
far what do we got predictions for
people who played the game Alma yeah
that's true that's a great point but I
feel like they might change some stuff
there's still something to talk about
Jordan Reese in the chat de San Nell in
episode eight did you notice melon
episode 8 no I did not someone did say
that Abby was there there's a little
girl with pony like I picked I don't
know what they were talking about I did
see someone post that I didn't re-watch
the part where they said it was like I'd
run the 30 minute Mark but yeah
yeah I have no idea what people are
talking about I feel like there would
have been images of that online but yeah
I haven't seen that so it's John thank
you buddy yeah no problem all right bye
and in regards to that comment about got
people who played the game making
predictions yeah I mean that's a fair
point but also too if anything episode
three taught us and other certain things
they they will change certain things up
so I mean they're not gonna be
completely perfectly faithful in every
which way so yeah it's fair okay so they
said de San Mel was sitting next to the
girl that got slapped by the preacher
Uh Oh you mean like the actress or the
actual care the actual character who is
the actual character I'd never heard
them say Mel yeah
oh okay okay yeah it's getting confusing
yeah but yeah guys go ahead and leave a
like on this because we did not get uh
our notification bells are not working I
was gonna say if it was Mel it wouldn't
make sense because I mean we're live
attack spoilers here right this whole
thing is going to be very spoiled sorry
guys I've been like really careful what
I'm supposed to say the last nine weeks
so like now I'm on like just I gotta ask
Greg type of thing now but
yeah if that was Mel in episode 8 which
it sounds like uh these people are
saying it's not it would make no sense
in terms of what happens in the second
game because we know that Mel is a
firefly and that she was there with them
in Utah so yeah that sure would make
absolutely no sense oh thank you thank
you so much Cody Maverick Andrew you see
your frame here yeah you're too much
you're too much in the Box oh wait I
need to reload this chat oh guys I need
to reload the chat here hold on let me
let me fix this for everyone
sorry Andrew
sorry Andrew I'm sorry it's okay you're
forgiving I'm sorry I was like oh yeah
this looks like no one's here at all on
a second let me get this going I'm gonna
fix this everyone I'm gonna fix this
hold on
I'm gonna fix this for everyone so they
can see their chat on screen
I wonder what would happen if I close
this out because I don't think it would
end the Stream
no no no wood hold on a second guys I'm
gonna fix this
hold on
I can't do it
it's not letting me do the thing we're
fixing anyway who do you think should
play Abby in the do you have a pick for
Abby because we're getting that like
that question quite a bit here in the
chat yeah they should just uh get Laura
Bailey and then do the CGI thing with
Mark Hamill right yeah that would be
great and that was the popular choice
originally I mean you know I mean I
don't have I don't have an actress in
mind I mean
I think they nailed their casting
choices when it comes to Pedro Pascal
and Bella Ramsey and I didn't have those
actors in mind when it came to those
roles so in terms of Ellie and Joel so
honestly at this point I trust Neil
directman completely and Craig Mason did
I say that right uh yeah okay because I
feel like I always pronounce his name I
trust them completely uh their cat the
casting that they did in season one
pretty much across the board was spot on
so I don't particularly have an actor in
mind that I'd want all I would say is
whoever that actor ends up being uh I
would
probably get off social media for the
next couple of years because there's p i
mean again I personally and thoroughly
enjoyed part two I understand how
divisive it is and I I get why I totally
understand respect everyone's opinion
towards it uh even if I don't agree with
some of the opinions but I would just
say a lot of the hate obviously came
towards Abby so whoever that actress is
whether it's accomplished or not it Just
immediately like you're gonna get into
that you know you get into that fandom
of there's gonna be people out there who
are not going to be happy with that
character just from the game so
I would just caution whoever that
actress is about social media and just
not taking things too personally I feel
like uh you know who I saw as a pick
there it is I figured it out oh yeah
Didn't I figured it out guys look look I
did it I'm a genius
um really quick not interrupt you there
was an actress that we saw he said not
to interrupt me I am I'm sorry I just
wanted I just wanted to remind you there
was an actress we saw I showed you like
a month ago she looked just like Abby
and you're like oh yeah I know this
actress is that who you're about to say
no no no I was gonna say okay all right
guys sorry I was trying to get this chat
on screen that way you could actually
see what everyone's saying too
um yeah no what I was what I was hearing
a fan pick that I've been seeing going
around a lot is actually
um Florence pew
and I was like you know what yeah there
it is cloud 19 just said it right there
I was thinking yeah Florence Pugh
actually wouldn't be a bad pick I don't
think she'd be a bad pick uh how
I mean Abby is what in in the games I
mean I feel like her and and uh Ellie
are roughly around the same age right
who gives a [__] she can play Abby yeah
I mean as a young face yeah that she
looks really young I guess no no that's
that's true but yeah I I am curious too
about that actress I'm not saying they
are gonna pick her but that actually I
don't remember her name the one I showed
you like a month or so ago but we both
looked at her like holy crap this looks
just like Abby uh yeah Shannon Barry I
think was her name oh okay yeah she like
I could totally see her just I mean from
a visual I I don't know her acting range
but
what was your guys's favorite episodes
ah good question
um yeah jabby heard I was going to be
doing a spoiler talk and then he was
like I'm gonna go ahead and do that too
that's how this goes
freezer money says please know she's a
bit too traditionally pretty you see I
feel like
I I don't think Abby's I actually don't
feel like Abby is ugly like a lot of
people feel
um but she I think the thing with Abby
is she needs to have the physicality as
well so yeah this this whole thing uh of
this talk today is is meant for people
who just played I realize if we just did
a live spoiler talk people would be
spoiling the game so we might as well
just talk about the actual
um we might as well talk about like
full-on spoilers today for people
outplay the game so we don't expect like
a bunch of people to be in this live
stream today only because of the fact
that most people a lot of people who
actually watch our videos like oh a lot
of people comment actually haven't seen
it either yeah
um this is this shirt right here is a
real reject exclusive one thank you for
asking oh and then we got a super chat
here from Dakota let me go find that
super chat here thank you Dakota Dakota
Jones Thank you thank you so much for
contributing he said I'd be a liar if I
said I didn't want more clickers uh I
would have but they kept the baby girl
moment and for that I am happy need more
action in two I agree do you guys know
how they how they baby girl moment came
to be in the in the video game itself
how that translated actually into this
do you know the history with it I just
remember he called her Sarah baby girl
but I don't know the history of how it
became a line no okay educate me so what
happened what Andrew you're way too
close to the screen let's move you over
you have to have some mindfulness here
mindfulness please I'm a Noob when it
comes to the live stream so um what
happened was uh Troy Baker it was it was
a line that I believe it was with he was
doing a scene with uh Sarah when they
were making the last of us one and Troy
Baker had uh he was like improvising
some lines and he said baby girl to
Sarah and Neil druckman was hearing that
and he's like what did you say and he
Troy Baker wasn't sure what it was and
then he said was it baby girl because
that's such like a common thing
apparently that Texans say and right
then and there Neil druckman said that's
it that's what you're gonna call Ellie
later on and that became like an iconic
moment for it and it was actually Troy
Baker who improvise saying that and then
Neil druckman took note of that and
wanted to infuse that in there dude I
love honestly I love stories like thank
you Troy Baker by the way that's awesome
that's awesome but I love stories like
that when you hear about actors
improvising such iconic lines Han Solo
and Empire Strikes Back you know I know
after Leia says I love you and also of
course the great Roy Scheider God Rest
his soul in Jaws when he says you're
going to need a bigger boat like I love
when these actors just improvise such
iconic lines like that and then they're
like just seared into our heads when we
think about these scenes but that is
such a cool story and I I never knew
that uh Cartman 1414 in the chassis and
whoever it is I pray for them the
backlash Laura Bailey got was oh it was
terrible see that's that's the thing
that I feel like is a little bit
worrisome for whoever is going to be
playing Abby is that it's going to be
one of those cases it's on it's
unavoidable as much as there's gonna be
people like I see a lot of people in the
chat who are very sound and logical
about it uh we're gonna be very logical
about it there's gonna be so many people
who are just going to become in an
uproar especially now that Pedro Pascal
is this like national uh like not even
now like a worldwide sensation right now
once they cast Abby once Abby is cast
like I feel sorry for pretty much
it's one of those things where even if
you haven't played the game odds of you
getting it spoiled for you are gonna be
insanely likely like people are gonna go
why is everyone pissed off about this
Abby casting people are just gonna find
out and so many people aren't gonna have
it ruined for them and then of course
it's going to be the thing where the
actress for some reason gets the blame
and it's not like the cool kind of
Burden you gotta bear when you're like
your cast is Batman you'll get some crap
but don't worry you can win them over
the character of Abby is already a tough
one to crack for people and so I I
already feel sorry for whoever it is
that's gonna be playing that and I'm
sure again like the the warnings that
we've given out I'm sure that they're
gonna talk to whomever that is just
about social media and all that like hey
it might be a good idea to I mean do
obviously whatever makes you comfortable
but it might be a good idea to possibly
get off just because out of your control
people are just take it very personally
when it comes to that specific character
and know we don't want you getting the
brunt of the hate before you even get in
here to film anything and like have that
affect your performance because I mean
you know for me personally again I I
understand you know the divisiveness of
of Last of Us Part Two and also with
Abby I I get it you know we We Grown
Sona attached to Joel and Ellie and we
don't want anything happening in these
characters and I I know a lot of people
have also said it's not just the fact
that it happened to Jill it's the way it
happened but I've also tried to say hey
like the last of us to me is always
about moral perspective and you know if
you put yourself in happy shoes I I can
imagine you would feel the same way the
same hatred she fell towards Joel and
you'd want to get a Joel in one as well
so I mean
again I just caution that actress I'm
sure she's going to do a fantastic job
again if season one has shown us
anything they Neil druckman Craig Mason
they know how to freaking nail casting
so I'm sure whoever they pick is going
to do an amazing job and like I said
just just be careful on social media I
think that too there's there's a sense
of Fate as well when it comes to the
last of us like something of like Joel
who's you know he's looking for Tommy
but then he ends up
running and finding him in a spot where
he wouldn't expect to find like it feels
like he ran into him as opposed to I was
searching for this exact spot and then I
found him and it's just kind of the same
thing that happens with Abby in the
second game when Abby does encounter
both Joel and Tommy it's like
there is a sense of Faith so I don't
know it's not about the golf club the
first time I played it really bother me
but the second time around doesn't
really bother as much well you made a
good point you said
I mean again this isn't for everyone but
I I know you I remember when you said
this I I still enjoyed it a lot the
first time I played it especially the
gameplay was just so much fun it was so
much more fluid and I know you can't
always compare games when they're seven
years apart because obviously there's
going to be technical Feats that are
achieved years later but when I played
the game back to back with the first to
second one it just flowed so much more
seamlessly and I enjoyed it so much more
and you're the one who suggested that to
me because I I didn't play the first one
immediately right before I played the
second one the first time and
it kind it definitely bothered me the
first time I played it as well but then
immediately playing after the first
one's like okay this this flows a lot
more makes a lot more sense with just
again with you know how it's going with
the uh after immediately following the
first one so
yeah that was a good suggestion I mean I
feel like they kind of prime you for
that too because Craig Mason and Neil
druckman said that they thought about
like The Following Season while crafting
this season yeah like the whole
overarching story that's why I get so
many season two Easter eggs uh on or or
not even Easter eggs
foreshadowing and World building uh to
establish the grounds for season two and
then changing up some plots and themes
in order to have it segue better and for
the themes of season two Jacob C said if
we're doing full spoilers I hope we
spend more time with Joe before he's
killed off I don't want it to be in the
first episode or two I'm I'm okay with
that if they do that uh I mean
I I believe that they've announced or
have hinted at the whole part two is not
going to be in one season as was this
one I mean you you can't do part two in
in one season not Nine episodes if it's
gonna be in one season it's got to be at
least what 18 to 21 episodes I mean the
length of part two I know again that
they cut a lot I know the argument's
probably going to be made they cut a lot
of stuff out so you probably get a
couple episodes out of that from all the
stuff that they do cut out yeah but I
really feel like it you got to make this
two parts like it's it's too long to do
one season yeah I don't feel like I
really don't think that if they did it
as one season it would do the storage
like because the Last of Us game is is
relatively short yeah the first one
especially for a for a video game
experience it's a pretty short game
um all things could I mean still you
have to dedicate some time to beat it
but it's all things considered but The
Last of Us Part Two that's a that's a
real journey you gotta go on and that's
a commitment to to beating that game I
am curious though structurally how they
would do because for those if you don't
care about spoilers and you're here cool
uh but just a quick refresher on how it
goes is you first play as
you primarily first play Ellie as Ellie
and after Joel dies she's on the hunt
for Abby and then when after several
days eventually she does come face to
face with Abby then it backtracks and
then you focus on Abby's perspective and
storyline on those same days and you get
to understand her life who she is where
she's kind of she has this whole other
Adventure that has nothing to do with
trying to find Ellie uh it deals with
the seraphites who are are more of like
uh this cultural tribalistic type of
people and Owen and Owen who Andrew
would be a great Owen casting by the way
and so you you have these people of her
being with the fireflies and then she
comes into to encounter Ellie
and then after they have a conflict and
it goes back to Ellie and she's like you
know what I still want revenge so it's
it's a weird structure too to begin with
is whereas The Last of Us the first game
is so linear you know it's a it's just a
straight shot you know to the fireflies
is basically the journey what you see
unfold in the like if anything they took
creative liberties with the structuring
with the the this first season of the
show has more of a complicated structure
than the the video game does
so I have no clue at all how because
like there's one one theory that sounds
neat to me to divide it into a couple of
Seasons would be if you did the first
hat like the whole LD side as one season
and then you continued it from at but
from Abby's side or I think what they
would have to do though to really get
you on on board this journey is you
would eventually just have to cut back
and forth between the two I think that's
that's the smoothest way you can do it I
would personally think that was is the
better way because again you're gonna go
you're gonna have the whole season I
mean again for us Gamers who know what's
up like we're gonna haven't understand
what's going on but in terms of the
Casual fan who doesn't know what's
happening I think that's the smoother
and smarter you know thing to do because
you want people also being invested in
Abby you don't want the the same
divisiveness that you had in terms of
the game so if you're trying to get
people on board just focusing on Abby
that first season and then stopping it
right there and like all right there's
this character that just killed this
this character that we've grown in love
with uh sit on that for a year and then
we're gonna come back to her I I just
don't think that's I don't know I don't
think that's going to be the right move
and it's going to be a tougher selling
game people invested in Abby sitting on
a year of not seeing her perspective or
her point of view and then coming back
to that a year later I don't know I just
feel like that would be tougher so I I
think you're 100 right that would be the
smoother transition to keep cutting back
and forth and it would be definitely a
you know deviate from the game for sure
because obviously like you said it was a
completely different story structure for
the second game which I thought was cool
I you know what I actually enjoyed it I
mean you can make a case like it ruined
a little bit of the pacing of the second
game but I actually thoroughly enjoyed
this whole Revenge trip because I mean
that's what we all felt at first because
we want to get revenge for Joel and then
again the whole moral dilemma moral
perspective of where Abby's coming from
and you understand like hey you you know
Joel's not just taking out you know
nobody like these people have families
uh there's consequences and
ramifications to Joel's actions and
that's what I appreciate yeah about the
second game so much I thought they
really hammered that home with fleshing
that out on the world of the first game
too of the first season of the show
though too because you spend so much
more time humanizing other characters
that you normally wouldn't humanize yes
and because they took the time to really
do that that sets the groundwork for
what occurs when Joel ends up dying in
the second in this I'm presume in the
second season and if anything I feel
like they're probably going to give us
more flashbacks with Joel definitely
yeah as Oppo because you don't really
get that much time with Joel in in the
second game even in the form of
flashbacks and I think this time around
you'll get way more flashbacks yeah I I
pers again this is my personal uh thing
that I think I don't think they're gonna
kill him in the first couple of episodes
I think it's going to be a little bit
long maybe four or five don't know but
there's definitely going to be a lot of
flashbacks when it comes to you're not
just going to get completely get rid of
Pedro Pasco you're going to want to you
I mean when you got okay Pedro Pascal
man you got one of the biggest stars
ever and he just owns the role of Joel
so I mean if they
if there's one thing that besides the
casting that I mentioned that Neil
druckman and Craig Mason did beautifully
in the first season they expanded upon
things that were not you know touched
upon in the game in such a beautiful
methodical and interesting way and I
think they're gonna like again do that
with flying colors in the second game
and you can do that with a lot of the
flashbacks because the FL a lot of the
flashbacks are some of my favorite
moments in the game when they go when he
takes Ellie to the museum and you know
the what he does for her for her
birthday like that's one of my in both
games it's one of my favorite moments
ever like the joy he gets in her face
like in the I mean just getting them
together like I love moments like that
so I'm assuming that they're gonna have
definitely a lot of flashbacks and use
Pedro Pascal as much as possible because
you're good the non-casual fan you are
gonna get upset that they've grown so
invested in Joel whether they agreed
with his decision what he did with Ellie
here at the end
a lot of people are invested in Joel uh
again we're talking about non you know
Casual Gamer fans that are watching the
show so they're going to be really upset
and you know what's the re-watch ability
here now in season two when this
character is gone but if they know hey
there's a there's a lot of flashbacks
okay no I can keep coming back this
because I know even though I'm I'm upset
at the notion that he has gone
understanding the ramifications of what
he did and there are consequences now I
know hey there's a lot of flashbacks I
get to still watch him and see the
in-between stuff that led up to this
that's true that's a good point
I deleted EXO saying I really hope they
don't cut out the Rat King in season two
uh I I could see if if they are doing
what what Greg was mentioning in terms
of going back and forth between Ellie
and Abby if you remember that does
happen way later on Abby's Journey
because she's trying to get the medicine
for yara's arm uh before they do the
surgery so yeah I would imagine I agree
with you I don't think they're cutting
the Rat King out that I'd be really
upset about if they if they cut that out
and of course I would get accused of
being a complainer but
um I don't see them cutting out the
racking but I do see that happening in
season three I just think it's way too
far along in the storyline for that to
be season two what about you uh I think
your face is being cut off by the chat
right now and uh it's such a leaner
um I think what happened I think for
season two what they need to First
rebuild up the
Mason did say that there when it comes
to the infected that if they thought
that it didn't drive the narrative
forward the story forward they were
going to just excise it that it wasn't
really a question yeah but I but I know
they listen to I know they pay attention
to what fans are saying not that like
Neil druckman is one two becomes
observient to advance one not like he's
gonna undo what happens to Joel in the
second game
I think though that that is a I think
the complaint though based kind of
reading in between the lines I could see
how they might have seen some validity
to what some people have said uh because
it is kind of a common thing because
I've even heard non-gamers say that they
felt like there should have been more
infected I've heard quite a quite a few
people say that uh just to really help
that that part of the world feel more
lived in and I think you need to see
more of that like before we go to rat
king we need to really see a bloater I
think you need to see like the bloaters
really in action like you only got like
a t if anything you got a teaser trailer
for what a bloater is capable of yeah
but none of that real high suspense like
in the second game there's this section
where because as a quick refresher what
what is she's part of the wlf wll she's
part of the W Washington Liberation
Front Abby's part of the Washington
Liberation Front and Isaac's in charge
territorial they're a territorial war
with the uh Andrew I will get there I
will get there Mr interrupted just give
me a second give me just like like two
two extra seconds and I'll get there as
an end to support anticipatory is this
what you do at the jabby COA Channel
always I always interrupt does he yell
at you actually actually never he's like
interrupt as much as it's probably
because he's not smart enough to get to
the point himself and he's relying on
you whereas I know my brain will
eventually get there sorry go ahead I'm
sorry you don't have to be sorry just be
better you know what I mean okay you
know what I'm saying I'll be better Greg
you know what I'm saying buddy so uh yes
what we're even talking about Sarah you
were talking about Sarah fights that's
where you come in thanks man it's so
deserophytes and because there are war
with the certifieds and it is a thing or
like they you know they learn all these
ideologies that Abby has developed over
time by being part of wlf and like you
know what I have a misconception of what
a lot of these people are actually like
but one of my favorite sequences in the
most intense sequence one of the most
intense sequences a lot of people go to
the Rat King for what is so scary and it
is a scary sequence in The Last of Us
two game but one of the scariest moments
to me is when
um she's escaping with Lev and and Yara
and then she gets trapped in that house
and she and she can't get out she's at
this battle like all different varieties
of infected Abby remember that sequence
and that's and she thinks that like 11
Yara abandoned her yes yes that scene
right there I'm like that would be such
a great live action sequence and that is
one where I'm like I beat the way you
felt in episode 8 about them skipping
that scene I'm like
I could see how you can get away with
not including that scene like you don't
necessarily need that sequence yeah but
it would really bother me just thinking
I had it I mean maybe in the moment it
won't bother me so much but right now
I'm like ah I I really hope they bring
that sequence of life because that is
wildly intense that's one of the part
that's one of the aspects of the of the
fear building of the world of like that
is insanely scary when you're playing as
Abby in that moment and not only that
but again it's storytelling action you
know what I mean it's character
development action in terms of like Lev
doesn't want to like save or help Abby
like she she's a Sarah even though she's
an apostate she is a certified at the
end of the day she believes in what she
believes and this is a wlf you know
member and she doesn't want to save her
so it goes so far along in building
their relationship building the trust
between them yeah you can't skip over
that but again it's again it's not to
defend myself but that's the reason why
I was as you just mentioned a little bit
upset at the episode eight I mean
there's been so many action sequences
cut out that I didn't say anything I
said hey visually would have been cool
if they included them would it added a
uh you know a long way to go in terms of
just the World building and
understanding like oh my God like this
world is just really full of infected
and like there's no Safe Haven anywhere
but in terms of like when it's when it
comes to story building or storytelling
action or character development action
that's those are the bits I really want
included and I agree with you that's I
mean I wasn't even thinking about that
moment honestly like the Rat King if
anything that's not even a necessary
it's if you think about it it's really
not a necessary thing for the story it's
not but visually damn I want to see
through yeah I know that's scary like
there's a there's a tad bit of fan
service that I think you kind of there's
a tiny bit you gotta uphold you know
yeah if it look I I'll look at it this
way you know if if season one is alien
then season two's got to be aliens yeah
the Slow Burn type of thing where you're
barely seeing the monster and then
season two it's James Cameron let's go
all out let's let's shoot some monsters
all over the place all right so
um Ellie became a Comics boy P says in
the chat and uh thank you to everyone
who's contributed to Super chats by the
way support means a lot thank you
um that so but I'll be so we're just
going through everyone's comments today
so thank you we will go to the Super
Chat uh where'd it go
how are they going to get LA to be
buffer season two Jack says they don't
need to recast Elliot all they will make
it worse I'm not recast and they already
said that belly is here to stay and also
too in real life Bella Ramsay is 18 or
19 years old so she was 17 when they
started filming yeah I don't think
that's going to be a problem in regards
to how she's going to get buff I mean
it's very simple she's going to go to
the gym she's going to eat nutritiously
and I would imagine that's how she's
going to get buffed I mean I like Ellie
became my favorite character like I love
Ellie in in in the first game don't get
me wrong I do
um in the second game that's when she
definitively became my favorite video
game character so to me I hold it's
gonna be hard for me
as someone who is so in love with I love
the second game and I love Ellie so much
in that
like there's that sequence
I love that sequence when she's like
[__] up all those wlf people you know
before
um what's his name give me the name
Andrew the Asian guy Jesse there we go
I just wasn't saying see how I am
invited that's why I didn't say anything
I was being better I was being better
you did better and I appreciate it I
have a character Arc even on a live
stream I'm so fleshed out when Jesse
shows up that whole sequence is is one
of the coolest I love that that is a
that is such a cathartic
like unleashing of like even though
these are not the P these are not the
the direct people who killed Joel you
could you really get that sensation of
like yeah you guys can go [__] yourself
like die and I I really love that moment
um and Ellie and that game like she's
she's brutal and she's unbelievably
tortured and and more mature and yeah
she does feel because she feels like
you're so much younger in the first game
because she is yeah that I am gonna feel
like it's gonna be hard for me to
completely wipe I mean who knows by the
time it comes out I'll be uh I feel like
every two years I'm a different person
honestly I feel like I'm a different
person every two years uh so by the time
it comes out I'll probably have a much
easier time just wiping my brain away
from the second game
um but I'm gonna hold the Bella Ramsay
to a bit of a higher standard for my
personal subjective viewing experience
because that portrayal of Ellie in there
is and I saw shades of it in in the
final episode here like that that she
did evolve because she seemed she did
such a good job Bella Ramsey at
embracing the child side of Ellie
that I found myself surprised by how
amazing she was in episode eight and
nine yes I'm like oh [__] she is pulling
off the other layers of Ellie absolutely
really well like she was so believable
as the child side of Ellie who was
um I don't want to say jaded but you
know just a much more innocent
um that by the time she gets to episode
eight and nine where she is becoming
more dejected and that trauma's Weighing
on her and becoming more Hollow and
she's talking in a lower register all
those things
I was really impressed with oh man you
really sold me to you were so good on
the childlike side that I didn't I
wasn't I wasn't 100 confident you could
pull off this other side yeah and then
you started proving it to me so yeah I
mean that there is a physicality to
Ellie uh and and in season two that she
would have to pull off
but I feel like I feel like uh she can
do it because she's gonna probably go
through a lot of training because by
that point Ellie's a much more
experienced uh hunter-gatherer and
whatnot yeah no you make a great Point
she really did a great job when it comes
to the child uh side of Ellie but he
wrote for Abby
I love that for Abby
oh boy yeah I'd love to I'd love to see
that uh but no I mean you make a great
point that she really did a good job in
terms of the the childlike ability that
she showed us uh and she really like
seriously the last two episodes
especially episode nine I was extremely
riveted by her performance I mean just
showing how much like the trauma of what
this cannibal that like wanted to make
her her pet and just as a complete
pedophile what it did her because again
as I mentioned she lives in a world of
infected and people trying to kill her
every single day so I mean that should
for for a 14 year old kid that should be
traumatic enough as it is yeah but what
David did to her like a part of her soul
was completely like just taken from her
in a sense and obviously Joel is like
The Last Remnant keeping that Soul
intact and when he's ripped away from
her like all right all bets are off and
she just goes on a violent Revenge angry
path I mean it's beautiful to watch in
the game like it's it's amazing she's
freaking incredible such a such a
three-dimensional character in that game
but
basically the point I'm making is Bella
Ramsey what I saw her do in episode
especially episode nine like when I saw
the the weight of the of that trauma
that David did to her like I'm like oh
she's like I'm ready like I can see that
rage is just like boiling beneath the
surface and I know Bella Ramsay's just
gonna like kill it in season two
literally and figuratively speaking like
I was just so floored by her performance
and especially episode nine like just
seeing I was like wow she really no she
really did it like I was really buying
her as as Ellie again like you said from
the child side but seeing her like
having that whole weight of the world in
her whole So Gone like she like that's
not easy to do body language and facial
white I mean she killed it that last
episode now she was excellent we're
gonna go back to the chattings uh I just
want to make sure because I I tend to
have a habit of taking way too long to
get to the people who did contribute in
the super chess but we don't have we
don't have like a a [__] ton of super
chats right now so I want to make sure
we can stay on track I'm gonna go pull
back to the um to the chat here just one
second
come on Greg I got to bed at like six in
the morning guys I'm very I I'm slowly
remembering how to live I I kept uh
texting and calling Greg all night about
how good that that episode was was my
fault that he didn't go to bed yeah dude
what's your problem Andrew I'm sorry I
just can't help it when I'm excited it's
okay buddy
just pulling it up here
no it's not working
you know what no I'm just gonna scroll
in the actual chat I got this
I got this everyone don't worry then I'm
gonna scroll back to where we left off
at
oh my God there's there's shortcuts I
know a shortcut to do this watch watch
Andrew have you heard of this option
called command F I have not heard of
Commando what does command F do Greg
basically allows you to just screw to
control fine it's amazing I was like oh
wait a minute ever hey our first Super
Chat from morenta59
well ND that's Neil druckman Neil
druckman not uh Notre Dame or not Notre
Dame uh high school well well Neil Young
would have enough time to finish part
three before season four is so part two
has has to be two seasons you can't tell
a 50-hour story in Nine episodes I mean
he hasn't committed to doing a part
three yet I mean he's he's like teased
he's had ideas on the horizon yeah and I
mean if they're gonna do part three
that's gonna take at least what four
four or five years probably to do in
terms of you got to write out the story
you got to write out the dialogue you
got to get all the stuff ready for the
game I mean that's a it's a like a video
game is it I mean everything is a
process TV shows are and films but a
video game is like a dedicated long time
especially nowadays with next-gen you
know all these new systems we have and
it's a it would take in my in my
estimation even if the story was ready
right now do you feel like it it'd be at
least what four or five years until it's
probably out yeah yeah so and I would
imagine season two is gonna happen mid
to late next year would probably be my
guess I'm going to guess that they're
going to start filming late late this
year I mean when you got a monster hit
like this I can't imagine that they're
going to take way too long to start
filming so my guesstimate is to start
filming later this year mid to late next
year season two comes out and then again
you're gonna have the the part three
which is going to be I'm guessing the
completion of part two of the video game
so season three and that's what 20 25
will be in at that point you're not
gonna have part three out by there's no
way part three will be out in in two
years like I just I mean do you see part
three being on two year in two to three
years I don't I know I mean I've and I
feel like they're I think there is more
room to tell because the way part two
ends Ellie doesn't get her revenge she
lets Abby and Lev go uh but she's lost
everything in the process in her pursuit
of Revenge you know she can't even play
with the guitar anymore she's lost Joel
she's lost
um Dina thank you I was I was blanking
no thank you so she lost Dina and in
that process uh you know she's left this
really Hollow thing
however she still is the one and only
person that we know of who is immune to
the virus and there's still so I'm like
you can you can't do that thing where
you bring it back that you know those
those great trilogies that bring it back
to the first one you can't bring it back
to the first one of you still are the
one who has the capability to help
produce a vaccine in this world and you
might be able to let that hope actually
pay off I'm all for that bleakness that
reality that harshness I love it it's so
sad and it weighs on you and it's mean
and I love it however you can end this
in a way where there you don't have to
end it with life where you got a vaccine
in the world that's cured but you can do
something where like maybe it's the
journey where she does get him they do
find a doctor where they can at least
start the process and it can just end
there you know what I mean like the the
doors left open of what could possibly
happen right
um so there you go I but yeah I would
love for them to do a part three oh for
sure I definitely especially with how
part two ended I definitely want to
continue it should be one where it's
like now Abby and and Ellie team up
well and left too right and Lev and then
and then you get uh Dina back it's just
a it's just a crossover we call it the
the the three five one then maybe and
then maybe if there's a ten maybe if
it's a time Jump we'll have JJ jump in
there too and then what they can do is
they can access uh the Multiverse and
they could get Joel back and go from
another dimension it's the Josh Brolin
version of Jill yeah yeah yeah that'd be
amazing
um all right so name Summit says in part
two oh thank you name something thank
you so much in part two after Joel
brutally killed by group wlf Tommy roll
become more important in game uh I hope
they also show how Ellie's perspective
changed in end uh Tommy's role becomes
more important yeah it's true you know
what in the game that Tommy has his
whole Adventure that's it like
they cast Gabriel [__] Luna you know
who's an amazing actor great
um so yeah so when it comes to
um when it comes to uh Tommy in in the
second game he has this whole Adventure
where while Ellie is hunting Tommy goes
off to go hunt as well to go track down
Abby and then eventually you know you
you cross paths and whatnot and you get
some of Tommy I remember being in the
game and when Abby shoots him in the leg
or something I was like you [__] you
better not freaking like they kill off
PAW Patrol
if it's so messed up and then he's
injured so much to the point where he
can't even go get revenge by the end
it's really heartbreaking you really
want him to try yeah yeah but what I'm
saying is like I think they could have
like a dedicated episode if they do play
around with time a lot here where you do
see
you you can have an episode where you do
get like all from Tommy's perspective
that would be really cool Gabriel Luna
to actually get that or you do cut or
you can have instead of doing two story
lines you could have three storylines
that that'd be a good way to mix it up
for season two I think if you have one
where you're following Ellie one where
you're following Abby which is the main
ones and then one where you also check
in with Tommy yeah because they are all
and then you could have ones where you
actually do focus on Lev and Yara like
when you catch up with 11 Yara Lev is
being exiled from the from the
seraphites in that in that game
um so they they could probably do that
thing where in season one where you
actually see the lead up to left being
exiled that would be great yeah again if
really get to know they're probably
really humanize the serif fights
beforehand and then you see how because
you get the whole thing with Yara and
yara's Mom uh there's this whole history
that they talk about that you don't
actually get a witness yeah and so
because a lot of people are thinking
about Abby Abby Abby right when
the thing that made me really when I
realized like you know what I I really
love this Abby character like I grew to
love Abby was the scene when when
um
with Abby and Lev and Abby and I forget
the line that leads into Abby saying
this
but Abby eventually turns to level when
Abby's like [__] up some of the wlf
and and then goes you're my favorite
you're my people you're my people that's
the line you're my people I remember
that moment because I was like
that was very moving like they if they
when they do this show they cannot skip
that beat that is such an important beat
yeah and um like Lavin Yara especially
Lev is such an important character and
I'm like we're not even really talking
so much about who's gonna play that
person but we can get so much more
backstory with them yeah I mean and
first of all Greg you can admit the
truth you became invested in in Abby
when Owen and her were in the boat and
had their you know Andrew I don't
appreciate sarcasm on this channel I'm
not I'm being honest I remember you
called me and said Andrew have you got
into this part yet it's like the best
scene it's like a full-on you know
sex scene in this game so like nudity
it's amazing anyways I agree with
everything you just said uh and also too
what I loved about that that is one of
my favorite lines what you meant uh the
you're my people I love that line so
much they definitely better keep that
line in yeah yeah definitely but I I
think what I love too about the whole
Lev and Abby storyline is in essence she
becomes Joel and Lev becomes Ellie not
from a perspective of you know she's got
the Cure or anything to to make mankind
back to what it used to be but more of
just that surrogate uh you know sun and
and type of uh mother type of bond ship
that uh obviously Joel father and
daughter type of bondship like I'm doing
everything at all costs to protect this
person yeah so I love that perspective
so I mean it gives Abby again that's why
I love Last of Us so much there's so
much moral perspective and so much these
characters learn from their mistakes and
when it comes to revenge and hatred and
at like that's what I love that Abby
goes through throughout the game and
Ellie goes uh throughout the game so I
mean yeah but in terms of cutting back
to Tommy I I'd really be shocked if they
don't have at least one episode where we
see stuff from Tommy's perspective just
again because again in season one we saw
how much stuff was expanded upon stuff
that wasn't even in I mean episode three
like none of that's in the game yeah for
the most part none of that's in the game
at all with Frank and Bill which and I
loved all that it was great
so I mean Neil druckman and Craig Mason
I mean the sky's the limit for them so
there are some stuff and I mean I
definitely would love to see some
flashbacks too just like you said
leading up to you know Lev becoming an
apostate and what led to that all I mean
there's so much stuff you can I mean
again the game is so damn long that it's
gonna take two seasons but there's so
much other stuff that you can layer
around it as well so I'm looking forward
to seeing what they're gonna do
John Lewis thank you for the Super Chat
I agree that I need more effective and
more importantly shame on HBO for not
featuring bricks and bottles shame
yeah it would have been way too hiding
if they had uh
if they had listen mode in here oh yeah
one episode I said where's listen mode
like come on I think they do got to
bring some of the I think I think it
would be they don't have to it would be
cool though if they did bring because
because the there is such a there is
such a release especially in the second
game when it comes to the action you
know like it is so motive because the
action in the first game is mainly
motivated by protecting and surviving
where the action in in the especially on
Ellie's storyline is like go in there
and murder you know it's like Joel's
Hospital scene but throughout the whole
game for her
um and then but that even that
individual scene is still about
protection in a lot of ways here this is
something much more
um of a moral debate and so I think for
that stuff like I love the idea of like
using the bricks to destroy the bricks
to distract is a great like video game
Trope but you know it took me forever as
a gamer to realize like oh to win a lot
of this I could throw the bottle at
someone's head and then stab them yes I
didn't know that for the longest time I
didn't either yeah I was like what a
great convenient way to like that would
have saved me so much time and hassle if
I knew that I could do that with so much
of these characters I mean you don't
want them obviously overdoing it it's
going to be trophy at that point but I I
agree I definitely would like to see
that a couple more times in regards to
your comment about we need more infected
100 and I believe that they have
actually Craig and uh Neil have said we
are going to have more action sequences
next season we're gonna have more
effective because we need to feel not
only the sense of like that this world
is inhabited by infected which we got
glimpses of for sure in season one we
need to feel the consequences and the
ramifications of the decision Joel made
like what what exactly is this world
that we're protecting in terms of trying
to get a vaccine for because in season
one it's like yes there was we again
there was plenty of uh you know there
were some scenes where major hordes have
infected but there was a lot of times
where it just felt like it was much more
overrun by humans rather than infected
so I'm looking forward to them getting
back to that so we can again just feel
the consequences and the ramifications
of the the decision that Joel made yeah
I'm 100 with you Andrew it's been a
little bit of catch up here do you think
they will kill Joel in season two yeah
first first 10 minutes first 10 minutes
they'll do a bash's head and I was
thinking five minutes but you beat me 10
minutes
um I hope they change yeah Jesse does
that Jesse's death does feel there is
there is a thing in the in the game
where I know we got more Super chats we
got to get to
um there is a thing in the game where
some of the deaths
they read like we're going for such real
life that sometimes people just die in
real you know that that sometimes they
can feel like anti-climactic when
characters die however Jesse was a
character but he didn't even see much
grief over yeah and and I feel like some
grief would be nice and to have a little
bit more of a moment to Jesse's death if
they do ultimately go the route of
killing him off yeah I think that would
be very much uh that that would help
Aiden she could Henry Golding to play
him
or they should white casting what are
you thinking Finn wolfhard I think
Andrew finally learned who Finn wolfhard
is yeah I finally saw Ghostbusters after
like yeah and you're like that's who
Finn wolfhard is yeah no but no I mean I
agree with you in in regards to Jesse's
death from the second game like no it
makes sense what happened but yeah I
want to feel the moment because it
happened so quickly and then Ellie
immediately goes to run after Abby or
rather excuse me you're the exact
opposite Abby goes immediately to run
after Ellie because you're in control of
Abby at this point yeah and
then after that there's a time Jump
we're now living on the farm with Dina
and Ellie and it's like I can't tell
that they're really sad and upset about
well they should be yes and that is that
is Jesse's child yeah that's his son
yeah
and that's what I mean I think also too
for
um you know if they do last of us at the
part three of the game
Ellie still has they still have a child
together and if child could grow up and
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah
Junior so e skinny rajo thank you so
much for the Super Chat uh oh what
happened did I lose it he's skinny there
you go not sure if this has already been
said but I'm disappointed that we didn't
see a Joel and Sarah photo at all on the
show let me is do you mind if I take
this one first
yeah I mean I'm not that disappointed
but yeah okay I feel at first I by the
way thank you so much for your
contribution really appreciate it at
first I completely agreed with uh what
you said and I would have still liked to
have seen that but the scene that we got
instead was so damn heartfelt was so it
talks about trying to take his own life
yeah and then like you're the reason
that I'm still alive like it was a good
substitute it was such a good
substitution that my Ma even though I
was expecting and hoping to see the
Sarah photo yeah my mind was like you
know what the scene is so damn touching
and that was the whole point of the
Sarah photo scene was to just kind of
say like I can't escape my past and
you're you know like having a daughter
is the reason worth living and like it
was just expressed so beautifully and
and
the the acting by Pedro Pascal and and
belly like oh my God the dialogue was
just so spot on that I was again at
first I was like oh they're not getting
the photo and then as I heard the
dialogue and I watched their you know
the way they were acting I was like okay
this is so damn moving I'm wow I love
this so much that it didn't bother me
anymore because of how good the scene
was well
I I think in a shorter run time too and
a live-action medium
it might read as like
instead of the new relationship that
Joel has with Ellie it might he's like
I'm replacing you
you know you could read a little weird
yeah not that it does to me in the game
does it yeah yeah like I wonder if in
live action it would read a little
strange like in the in the shorter run
time that you have I mean I always also
viewed it as you know not running away
from your past but I also just viewed it
as such as a thousand percent what it is
yeah but I also viewed it as well in the
game like such a heartfelt moment that
Ellie cares so much about jolta like hey
I got something for you and I wanted to
give you something that I I know you
would love even though I know it's hard
for you but you know I viewed it both
ways but again the the dialogue we got
and the acting from both of them just
completely made up for and justify that
not being in there in in my view but I'm
I'm so sorry that you were disappointed
that that was not included if it makes
you feel better I was disappointed in
episode even though I love the episode
The the actions once with David and
Nelly so I feel you you know what I love
about this car from Jackson Lane I can't
remember the actor's name I saw an
interview and said he really would want
to play Jesse in season two right now
what's happening is there's a lot of
people who see how great this show is
and there's so many actors who are
actually visiting or revisiting and or
revisiting the last of us too yeah and
they're trying to like can I play this
role can I audition now like there's
that's actually happening a lot that's
where actors are prepping stuff in
advance to try to submit to uh Neil
druckman and Craig Mason it's kind of
it's kind of funny you do that but uh
yeah that's that's really cool to see
though because because clearly the the
show's so Performance Based that it's
awesome to see it's inspiring a lot of
actors to try to go out there okay
what's up I was just going to say before
we read the Super Chat I heard I saw
someone say earlier we gonna get to see
the Rat King I also want to know are we
gonna when we get to Seattle in part two
in season two or season three oh it's
gonna be season two are we gonna get to
see some shamblers oh I want to yeah I
mean because it makes sense because I
know the whole justification for having
shamblers in part two and not having
them at all in part one is you know
they're the way they come about is
they're affected by water and obviously
in Seattle there's a lot of rain so it
makes sense like you know instead of the
or after the clicker stage before
bloated or whatever you turn into a
shambler so I'm looking forward to
seeing shamblers as well do you think
we're going to get to see shamblers
though in your opinion yeah we'll get
them for like one scene it'll never come
back sounds like stuff like the TV show
Olivia Hamlin thank you Oliver oh Olivia
oliviera is it Olivier is it I actually
oh I'm sorry thank you Olivier
um good afternoon gentlemen uh thank you
so much I can't wait to see how many of
the part two storylines unfold but very
excited to see how they pull off the
sunken Seattle what are some of the
parts you're most excited to see we
didn't get a lot I mean we're talking
about stuck in Seattle and Seattle's
kind of known for its uh dreariness and
of the rain and uh and I love like in
Last of Us one I loved so much of the
sequences with the snow and one of the
things I heavily associate with Last of
Us season two is the atmosphere of the
rain environment yes and did we get we
barely got I think it was maybe the
first episode where you get a tiny bit
of rain to towards the end am I wrong
about that of this show yeah a little
bit when uh when you went to that guy
yeah the federal guard yeah a little bit
we don't really get much rain and
there's a little bit with like
um Bill and Frank but other than that
you know that like that it creates such
a mood and atmosphere and such an
environmental condition they often have
to work against that it might sound like
I know I'm not listing off a specific
key sequence that is something that I
feel like really should be included it
does it does add to a lot of the
um this it weirdly adds to the
physicality stakes in a lot of the
sequences definitely I'm looking forward
to the Owen and Abby sex scene in on the
boat that's demonetized don't you Andrew
I do but no uh and actually in actual
seriousness I mean
specific sequence I don't know like the
scenes that had me I don't know if like
I I need to see them but the scenes that
had me on edge I'm afraid of heights
like Abby so when she was like trying to
climb that building with uh with Lev
like that freaked me out so just having
that my using my imagination that when
they're trying to get into uh you know
uh towards the hospital of like her up
on a crane like obviously you know I
think a True Lies up on that Crane and
stuff like that but just seeing Abby up
there I don't know if they're actually
gonna do that sequence but that would
terrify me right there
um but I hope they do that because they
did skip out on some cool building
sequences in the first game you sound
like Paul right now yeah yeah no they
did so because of that though yeah yeah
they like they should
because that's the something you said
that I'm like I could totally see them
skipping down here like no there's a way
to to condense this and sure I mean but
they got to play a part in that I mean
that's a big part of Abby's development
she is afraid of heights like that's a
big part of her character I could see
them totally just going screw we don't
need we don't need that in the show yeah
I could see them doing that yeah I guess
you're right I love the Trope though of
like big buff person who's afraid of
heights it is a it is a Trope I've seen
Amanda Doherty thank you Amanda
um Neil druckman can work on both the
showing he did it for the first Neil
druckman was working on King Kong and
saying Neil druckman
um was working on the second game while
developing the show uh the first season
of the show I mean yeah if he can
multitask and do part three and Seasons
two and three I mean go I mean he's got
a partner in Craig so I mean he's a
conductor he's not doing everything else
um Amanda dirty I'm a non-gamer player
and the morality conflict behind the
finale and looking back with hints
throughout is fascinating love your
discussions oh thank you so much
appreciate it
um yeah I I think that it's weird how
the second game kind of
vastly overwatched any type of moral
dilemma or conflict because that became
such a debate of the first hour of that
game
that I I forget like oh yeah yeah that
that was a controversial ending in the
first game wasn't it yeah like I wasn't
around for the controversy because I
came around to The Last of Us pretty
late I wasn't aware of that like I
remember being very shook when playing
the game because if I'm not mistaken in
the game what it's what it's like just
tell me just tell me if it's truth and
he says yeah it's true and she goes okay
there's like a music in the background
right it's like it has like Crescendo
build and then when it goes away and she
goes okay and then and then the credits
it's very similar to how it played out
in the except in the show they don't
have a music it's just it's just the uh
it's just the atmosphere of the wind and
stuff yeah when they're having the
dialogue and I remember being really
shook by that of like oh he totally lied
to her in that moment like that really
hit so to to me what what I thought was
really fascinating is the fact that he
they really
I think what the show captured very well
was the horror behind the fact that he
is lying and how he is choosing to live
in this sort of
quasi fantasy about this whole thing you
know like that to me is like you've
become such a good liar about it that
you seem a little like Pedro Pascal you
seem a little bit crazy now whereas in
the first in the game I never felt that
you know like no he's yeah he's lying
but I don't feel like oh you've kind of
cracked a little bit have you you know
yeah no I mean
it's it's an interesting dilemma because
obviously you look at the perspective of
I mean there's there's two ways of
looking about it there's a the
perspective of Joel of course where
you know the last 20 years of his life
have been awful he's had nothing to live
for his Humanity has been completely
shed and Ellie has given him something
to live for and he he's just not losing
another daughter he was completely
powerless when it came to what happened
to Sarah and now that he's in control
right now he's not about to lose another
daughter
whereas hey but on the flip side if he
tell like she wanted her life to have
meaning and have purpose and you know
she didn't want she's also got
survivor's guilt and she doesn't want
you know all the all her friends and
everyone like from Riley to Sam and
Henry to Tess all these people that
protect and her mother and all these
people that protected her like in order
like there was a greater good cause to
to protecting her and she didn't want it
to all be for nothing and she wanted you
know to like the fact that hey I can
save the world if that cost me my life
like so be it but like Joel was just not
having them that's what creates this
more of the lemon like I know even
though I saved her I know if I tell her
the truth of what really happened I lose
her yeah so it creates like that's
that's why I love this so much it just
creates such a moral dilemma like what
do you do in that situation like you
want you want to keep your baby girl but
and also I mean again like hey I'm also
protecting her from the truth but I'm
also being selfish in the way that I
can't lose her I mean because that's
obviously that's a very big part of what
happens in part two like it's just
eating you can tell how much it's eating
him away of withholding that information
and Ellie can just like she can
completely she knows it's her dad at
this point they've spent so much time
together she knows when he's not being
completely honest and she just knows
that this is eating him up uh what he
has done and
it creates such interesting storytelling
and such a moral dilemma so that's where
I just think like I'm just like that's
one of my favorite sequences not only in
the game but in any video game in any
medium the scene where uh the the
flashback sequence in part two yeah
where Ellie forgives him and they have
the whole talk about like I was supposed
to like my life was supposed to have me
like I was legit I think I text or call
like dude I'm crying right now as like
one of the best freaking moments I've
ever experienced playing a video or not
I guess not playing watching a cut scene
in a video game just on any medium of
media like that was so freaking good but
I agree though the the moral dilemmas
and conflicts that come about in Parts
one and part two is just so they're so
fascinating I love hearing what boom
City says Ellie went up all alone her
greatest fear she told Sam that's right
she did say I'm a worried I'm gonna and
that's where she ends up at the second
game revenge is a is a Fickle thing you
know yeah but it could be cool too it
can be it can be no doubt look at John
Wick right yeah man he's not alone he's
got his dog stuff
I mean I can't wait to see jonathara's
reaction to the finale as well I can't
wait also I'm watching every video with
them a crooked
kind of torn on the finale thank you
crooked by the way thank you thank you
for reminding me to thank crooked I look
like a total [__] by now thank you in
the game I felt is love and
responsibility for Ellie Moore and the
show kind of just felt like Joel being a
lunatic which isn't bad I don't know
ought to be I guess that's kind of funny
uh yeah I mean it's kind of what I mean
by I felt like he cracked I don't feel
like he a hospital scene isn't
registered to me as he's being a lunatic
if anything I kind of felt a bit of the
it's more of the fact of when he's lying
and [__] where he feels like he's kind
of cracked and went a little bit crazy
um where in the actual shootout scene
to me it felt less of a conflict because
of the fact that we didn't really see
much infected that it seemed easier to
side with Joel in that moment yeah than
it did in uh the video game then in the
video game where you're like yeah but
dude we've been like having a really
really survive through like the craziest
amount of effect in this entire time
that's yeah you nailed down the head I
mean when you're dealing with as much
infected as you are in the game it's
like again even though I'm from a
parent's perspective I I totally
understand where Joel's coming from and
just being so invested in these
characters like we don't even know if Dr
Jerry Anderson is gonna get this like
he's just I mean obviously he's a very
smart man he knows the quarter steps
well he's a genius when it comes to that
we don't even know like if what he's
doing is gonna work we don't know if the
vaccine's gonna work we don't know if
he's going to be able I mean these are
all just guesstimates at this point I
mean well educated estimates but we
don't know but again it makes the
decision that much tougher in the video
game because the world is beyond
affected whereas here yes we know
there's infected but because we haven't
seen it happen as much it just makes it
a lot of it it's it's it's a much easier
decision for it's like I don't know go
save her like this world isn't that run
over like with in fact there's infected
but it's not that bad yeah
that's a good story it's very true
one sec
so I make fun of koi about
um let's see here oh my god oh dude I'm
on the right spot here
okay yeah I got an agreement there
Mareta five nine thank you so much
morentified this show left Ellie's whole
world view out of her last speech they
didn't include I'm still waiting for my
turn biggest disappointment from me
Andrew what are your thoughts on that so
they left Ellie's whole world view out
of her laughs at last speech they didn't
include the I'm still waiting for myself
but they did
didn't she say that
damn as my memory serve me incorrectly I
thought she said I'm still waiting for
my attorney whatever she said I was
completely fine with yes I mean if they
if they did forget that line which I'm
I'm guessing I'm forgetting the scene
already
um but I mean I I definitely like that
line it would have been nice to have
that inclusion like I said there's
liberty certain things that they do you
know put in and out of the show but I
don't know like if they would have had
that line in great it's not it it didn't
bother me because I I can't even
remember even right now at this point
but I agree with you it's definitely an
important line but I don't know didn't
bother me if they didn't include it but
it would have been nice if they did I
felt like the world I feel like that the
point still for me at least it's I feel
like it still came through yeah you know
of they already have the establishment
of because they gave didn't they give a
tad bit of add-on to our scene after the
giraffe scene they gave it like a couple
of extra lines yeah like I wanted my
life to have meaning or something like
that like I think that's a line in the
second game or something
no this isn't the first game I forget it
kind of blends to me after a while the
life having meaning is in the second
game yeah I don't remember if that's set
in the first game
regardless like it the whole point is
kind of driven home by the fact that
they they had that scene in the giraffe
after the giraffe scene where Joel's
trying to say like we can just [__] off
and go back to Tommy
and then they have the ending scene so I
feel like that world view is I feel I
feel like to me it's communicated uh at
least but I you know I will not try to
tell you to feel otherwise here
uh let's see here
it felt like a mentally ill man trying
to convince this girl she's his new
daughter
I don't know I kind of like a bit of the
craziness behind that yeah
look at the world he lives in he's the
last 20 years this man has been trying
guys like he's not had sorry he's not
had his daughter the last 20 years I
mean he hasn't had a reason to live so I
mean it's understandable why as you
would say he's mentally ill to the point
where he's going to do anything he can
and he went to Terminator mode and that
that hospital seemed to to protect his
daughter I guess as you said convinced
her even though she was already
convinced this was her her father just
from the actions throughout the entire
season but that's a that's an
interesting and fun way of looking at it
I'm gonna next time I watch I don't look
at it that way Dart Carr thank you so
much here thank you Dart
um says Hey guys love all your
breakdowns keep up the great work thanks
thank you it's all Andrew baby all
Andrew all day every day nah just
following what you say Cameron cordoni
thank you for your very first Super Chat
hey y'all during Joel's master in the
hospital if you pause at a certain frame
this is uh this is whatever it is yeah I
don't know I'm curious I have not
checked it that would be a true Easter
egg you can see a shadow of a female
with a braid in her hair running off
View
I wonder how true that is or if or if it
just seems that way I'm not I'm not
saying it's not true but so far in the
12 over 12 hours that we've had since
the episode has been released I have not
even seen one picture online just with
yeah yeah sure so again I'm not saying
it's not true but if it is I'm curious
why there's not even a picture out yet
of that yeah I mean like what is the
certain frame what like why do we do I
don't want to go frame by frame for that
whole sequence but
you play you you've played the second
game more recently than I have I have a
replayed I mean I have
um
Abby
did she go to the hospital after
the after the massacre happened or was
she there when the massacre happened
uh you're talking about the massacre
with the seraphites or no no the
hospital one
oh oh the hospital I'm sorry uh did she
go to the hospital after the massacre uh
or was she there she was there she was
there when it was happening she was just
somewhere where Joel didn't go so that's
right because she she has she yeah
and she tells Jerry like if it were me
I'd want you to do it if I'm you know
saving the world and producing it so I
do wonder if the opening scene of the
second game will be like a young Abbey
and seeing that from Joel's perspective
I wouldn't I wouldn't be shocked that
that would be an interesting way to open
it up for sure I love that as an opening
starting with a young Abby yeah because
I think
because this is it's such a it's a much
taller order like as opposed to you're
going to be forced to play as this girl
you know whereas okay I I don't want to
tune in anymore if we're not gonna if
Pedro Pascal's dead and now we gotta
follow this girl who killed Pedro Pascal
I think they're gonna have to try to get
you to sympathize for Abby yes much
earlier yeah and and clue you in to who
Abby to clue you in as to why Abby kills
Joel much earlier than revealing it much
later I totally agree with you but also
too that's going to build up a little
more time not only getting a little more
like getting that sympathy and empathy
that you feel for Abby getting you
invested in the character but it's gonna
build up more time and allow Pedro
Pascal's character of Joel to serve to
be alive a little bit longer before we
get to those flashback sequences with
him and Ellie so I I think that's the
wise move because again everyone is
everyone I haven't really seen any
negative comments towards performance
and how much they love him as Joel so if
you go immediately into how the game
does it and then you do that and then
try to get people on board with Abby I
think that's just going to be a much
tougher sell so I think you've you know
you're on to something when it comes to
let's start off with you know a young
ambulance get people on board with
empathizing and sympathizing with her
and maybe uh some semblance of investing
in the character so when it does happen
we at the minimum whether you like the
character or not yet at least have an
understanding and why the motivation is
there because again we've got a major
foreshadowing for that which you called
out right as it was happening I was
thinking of two in episode eight uh
where Alec I believe was the character
that Joel was just self-defending
himself I mean he didn't even you know
it wasn't he wasn't massacring people uh
where he did like with Dr Jerry Anderson
like he was just defending himself from
uh after they were leaving the
University of Eastern Colorado and you
know with the uh where he killed the guy
that stabbed him with the bat so but
this was someone's daughter or someone's
father rather and his daughter like he
wanted him dead and I was like ah such
major foreshadowing for uh you know in
terms of the Revenge stuff so I mean
again just getting people on board I
agree with you just with a young Abbey I
think that's the smart way to do it yeah
a thousand percent man
I mean yeah like you kind of have to
that's that's what I think like the
major change will be in terms of
structure is getting you to understand
why she kills him absolutely as opposed
to waiting
um let's see here yeah because they
waited over half the game to to tell us
that so I mean that's a tougher self
let's see here
shut up about what happens in season two
is this a spoiler talk dude I thought
the whole point of this talk is to allow
us to we heard everything we were not
allowed with the help from saying we are
saying dude we appreciate you being here
but the whole video and point of this is
to talk season two prediction like
that's that's the title in the video
yeah I feel like I was pretty awesome
about it
um what was the point of showing the
fungi Network once that's what I mean
like that's that's why I think it was a
great idea too that's why I think there
there are even non-gamer fans yeah
people are not who are also like
I really kind of expected it a little
more effect because they made such a big
deal out of it and then especially
having the network that doesn't really
come into like it happens in episode
five two and five two and five uh yeah
two and five is when it happens but
um
yeah it doesn't really factor into some
type of Crescendo with it you know yeah
no I mean I thought because they got rid
of the spores and and mass which I I
totally get I understand even though I
was a little sad but I get it this was a
great addition I was like and I remember
like we were phrasing it heavily after
episode two we're like wow oh my God
like it really feels like there's
nowhere to go like
well the whole thing was like we were
like okay the only way infected usually
come is in the game at least is when you
make so much noise and that's how
they're alerted to your presence yeah so
having this whole network it's like
there's really no safe zone so I I hope
they go more to that in the in the
second season so we you know just get
that level of fear and like hey they're
never you're never safe anywhere in the
world
keep Dina's Ella's girlfriend but make
the person who goes with her Jesse keep
Dina is Ellie's girlfriend to make the
person who goes no you I mean Jesse
technically goes with them even though
he gets there later but you you can't
like you're not gonna get rid of that
Dina is a very essential character and
their relationship is a is a major
driving point in part two you can't just
get let's get rid of Joel in part one
all right let's get rid of I mean you
can't I get what you're saying but you
can't you can't do that you have to have
Dina come on the journey I mean also too
there's and I get your hat saying I have
a replacement but it's got to be yeah
thank you so much thank you Samuel just
sending this because I'm incredibly sad
after watching the finale maybe this
will make me feel better I hope they
don't show the serophytes too much their
mystery and Menace is what makes them
interesting oh they're humanizing them
they humanize everything one thousand
percent they're being humanized everyone
being humanized uh I think we're gonna I
that's something I would I wouldn't mind
seeing an expansion on honestly like
as long as they keep it locked into the
perspective of very minimum level if
it's if you're if you're seeing the
serifieds through Lev's perspective yeah
instead of like let's see the leader of
the serified to really get to know them
for sure they're going to do that but if
you keep it into how Lev views it and
and locked into her perspective then
boom oh wait no his his yeah yeah I'm
forgetting I forgot uh yeah you keep it
locked into his then boom that would be
that would be the best way to still keep
that Menace alive and to add really
quick to your point I think we're gonna
because we saw in some notes when Dina
and Ellie were scavengering about in day
one that uh about Jacob and how he took
over you know that territory in Seattle
with the wlf I wouldn't be shocked that
they spend an episode like again getting
their perspective humanizing the wlf and
then showing how Isaac took control of
that entire area and how he took control
of the wlf in general I wouldn't be
surprised we got an episode of that yeah
didn't they get Jeffrey Wright to play
in the game yeah did they I think it was
Jeffrey Wright because that would be
that it could wait a minute if it was I
have no idea but if not they should get
him either way
last of us too
he does play Isaac oh okay I never how
cool would it be if they got Jeffrey
well that would be perfect he already
looks like Jeffrey right so they got
Jeffrey Wright to reprice his role for
the last of us too just like Merle and
he's already part of the HBO world
because he was on Westworld yeah oh my
God that was I didn't even think about
that until right now that would be
amazing I agree with you yeah keep
Jeffrey right as Isaac please good for
guys to freaking for you guys forget
Isaac as leader of the wlf which is the
group that Abby belongs to doesn't know
what he always I just want to just
refresher Jesus Christ I know I thought
you were reading a comment saying that
to us I'm sorry no
Jesus Andrews I'm sorry I'm sorry
please forgive me Tommy's oh that's true
this is actually a great Point Tommy's
child in the show is what's going to
pull that's something we're going to
have to deal with in the show is what's
going to pull Tommy out of the darkness
from losing Joel's in part two Tommy is
an absolute husk shell of a man after
the events of the game uh Louis Ramirez
says that's a great Point yeah we Toby
doesn't have a kid in the game so yeah
now that he has a kid what makes his
decision to go on a revenge tour a lot
tougher because you have a kid and I
mean again yeah we understand where he's
coming from his brother was just
brutally murdered so you get the
motivation there but it's a tougher
again moral dilemma because he's got a
kid like there's like he's got a lot
more to lose than just Maria so I I
think that that was actually a nice
addition that they did to the show
uh Shamir Kelly thank you for the Super
Chat thank you uh let me make sure I
didn't skip anyone
and make sure I didn't skip anyone hold
on a second
you just make I'm just making sure
no no okay this is my first time super
chatting since part two game is going to
be over two seasons do you think they
can push Joel's death late in season two
of push into season three to have more
time showing Abby's side you see I
thought about this and I'm I I think you
gotta get to what is the plot about like
and and at the end of the day the plot
of The Last of Us too I mean there's two
main plots the plot of the last like the
Abbey one's a little bit more I don't
know if the right word's ethereal but
it's not as like directly focused it's
more of an exploratory that becomes a
narrative eventually a strong uh through
line eventually about wlf and certifieds
whereas Abby Ali's story is it's
straight up it's just a Revenge story
and so you kind of have to get to that
story yeah otherwise they're just doing
a bunch of explore I think they would
push Joel's death to maybe like episode
three or four I could see that but like
what would the narrative storyline be
other than just character exploring like
what is what is the plot I'm talking
about like what is the plot of this yeah
the character development it's one thing
but you need a plot surrounding it so
you could do a bunch of character
development and really postpone that but
I think I think they would at least
reserve it to like episode three I mean
yeah it's it's going to be at least
three or four five at the absolute
latest because again that's what drives
the plot you know that's when the plot
really starts in the video game is when
Joel dies and now Ellie goes on this
revenge tour so if you leave that to the
end of the season I mean yeah it's now
season three is gonna be condensed even
more than it you're gonna you won't even
be able to finish season three in the
amount of time it's it's gonna take so
I'd be really shocked if it goes past
five even at the latest
um the Elena I've never played the game
but I wish they should they should have
filmed what happened after or the
conversation after episode eight and
Dave and her Ellie were counting it to
Joel thoughts I mean they could have I
just I think they because of Bella
Ramsey's such a good actress I think
like it was it was pretty much conveyed
in how she felt and what she was going
through like I mean look look how much
they changed like just from the trauma
she was dealing with look how much Joel
and her changed Joel was usually the you
know the the outspoken one and the one
who was more like reserved and not
talking and Ellie was the one always
talking trying to cheer him up and all
that the Revolt the uh roles had
reversed rather so I mean we could I
didn't really need a conversation I mean
the whole comfort of him calling her
baby girl and then knowing what she went
through and then the scene we got after
that that kind of told me what I needed
to know so I personally didn't need a
conversation how did you feel
nope didn't need a conversation
salty salmon thank you it says Andrew we
love you oh thank you salty from the
cinepal side love you too salty salmon
thank you the title literally says
spoiler talk Greg has spoiled so much
already yeah no it's a spoiler talk and
and it says season two predictions wait
so in spoiler talk we talked about
spoilers season two and like part two
yeah you got you're on you're on your
own here literally I made it clear in
the thumbnail it says season two yeah
all right maybe in the thumbnail is
there a certain characterization try
trickied you into being here and
spoiling it and I was aware that there'd
be a lot it wouldn't be that many people
on the live stream because of the fact
that we were going to talk about that
yeah the video was called non-spoiler
and season one thoughts I'd totally
pretty much made it clear that pretty
much made it clear so don't [__] if
you're here
um pandemic Jones PJ my man thanks for
being here dude thank you Pedro Pascal
is one of the biggest stars right now I
think they show what happens between P1
and P2 uh the parking floors
for the majority of S2 then they end the
season with offing Joel and Ellie and
Dean are on their way to Seattle
thoughts
uh you know that's actually not a bad
call that's the best way I can see it
happening is if they invent a whole new
like storyline to
to maybe develop Ellie into uh the skill
set that she has because they yeah
because in like the first game when
she's she's hunting for Joel like Joel's
been um bedridden for a while so she's
had to develop skills on her own and
then we get to part two she's she's
really skilled and qualified and yeah
and all these things yeah so yeah I mean
they could do that but I still feel like
Joel's death is going to come in like
episode three or four I don't mind if
they do it if it's done in an
interesting way but the only thing is if
you do that where you kill him towards
the end you're gonna have to condense it
into three seasons it's gonna have to be
three yeah I don't ever have to it would
have to be three seasons and again if
you want to do that that's fine I don't
I don't mind watching three seasons I'm
cool with that yeah again if you do that
Neil and Craig that's fine with me if
it's done and executed in a good you
know good way go for it
uh Judith shetsky I didn't say the scene
with Joel and Ellie talking about him
nearly killing himself as touching I saw
it as sick and sad that he's putting
this on the struggling girl I hope they
explore it's toxic well I mean they talk
about like the dangerous side of love
and yeah there is a bit of this like um
uh I forget the psychological term
some displacement it might be the word
uh you were yeah you project it is a big
projection thing and that but there is a
toxicity that that does occur within you
know Joel like there is a toxic side of
it it's he lies to her you know like and
he did to give her a choice there's so
there is a toxic side to it and I I kind
of like that they lead with it it is
touching at the same time like I think
that's that's part of the cool thing is
that there's a gray area to it is that
it's not a hundred percent negative not
100 positive
um
yeah yeah ramoni Bernie I'm I'm right
there with you homie I'm right there
with you we need to have that scene
let's just all hope we don't get a jewel
in one the very first episode of the
season it's not happening in episode one
okay I can guarantee you that is not
happening I wonder if they'll change it
from a golf club
I mean they've definitely I mean like
look even in episode nine like in the uh
video game when the fireflies caught
them they you know they were in the
water and she she couldn't breathe he
was doing CPR and so they definitely
take Liberties so I mean it wouldn't be
shocked uh but yeah we'll see what
happens
the golf club thing was just so
demeaning it's so degrade how how would
you in your opinion like if they don't
do the golf club what would you be okay
with them like how would you feel like
okay I'm okay with this now
um a bowling pin okay yeah I could see
that I hope they're like I'm in the
mayor's house and yeah I mean the reason
that the golf club the reason the golf
club thing I'm not going to say works
for me because obviously I didn't want
anything to happen to Joel love Joel but
Abby made it very clear in the line like
oh no it's not going to be that quick or
something like she made it very clear to
Joel like this is going to be painful
and long so I mean it makes sense that
just torture the man before she kills
him
um Jeremiah says Stephen young is Jesse
people will lose their [__] thank you
Jeremiah by the way thank you Jeremiah
thank you Andrew that would be amazing
um if Stephen young did it may I see who
Stephen young is you don't know Steven
yanis and I just work on the internet
and in movies so I I don't know who this
is oh my God Andrew you're I'm trying to
be honest here I don't want a line be
like oh yeah Stephen you're great you're
a disappointment I know I don't know
anything
uh yeah I could definitely I Glenn from
The Walking Dead I never watched the
walking he's a nope I nope I never saw
that uh he's in uh a bunch of other
things he's he's the voice in Invincible
never saw it either but I mean it sounds
like he's a very talented
consume more content I I know I do but
no I mean just from the images I yeah I
could see him as Jesse for sure in terms
of acting range and ability I will take
my buddy Greg's word here on if he
thinks he could do a good job but just
on a visual presentation he could
definitely be Jesse he looks like him
deleted X oh thank you for the Super
Chat imagine season two starts off with
the Joel in one scene then the intro
plays I would love that uh there is a
part of me that would kind of respect it
of course
and then they go back like like then
they go back but they're letting you
know he dies like right away
there's there's no way they're gonna do
it no chance I don't believe in one
second but uh the amount of people that
are invested in not only the character
Joe but Pedro Pascal as Joel you have
there's there's a business side to this
and there's a re-watch ability side and
you are not killing your man this is an
alien three you're not killing you know
some of your main characters off in the
first frame here yeah
turning Joel into John Wick After Eight
Episodes of realism was pretty lame that
and the raid rage rat in the road rage
bloater are my only complaints for the
entire season what an amazing show
overall
well I think that's the thing about the
action like I wasn't bothered by it
because you see an episode
um uh eight in episode 8 you know with
the right amount of motivation
Joel's can turn that Darkness into a
kind of hyper Focus like he is he is out
of it he just got hit with Penicillin
but he is still recovering in episode
eight but he is jacking up dudes left
and right in there just to try to get to
Ellie and nothing's gonna get in his way
so I think like him going full
Terminator is not actually that far I
could see how it could look that way
yeah um but to me it actually it worked
uh even in the show structure because
they did a good job at establishing like
he went from someone who was paralyzed
and worried that he can't protect her to
that when the moment calls for it when
it truly is life or death for Ellie
there's going to be a darkness that
comes out of him that will cause him to
hyper Focus well and I saw that I mean
the foreshadowing too for me is him
turning into John Wick if you will and
that anger that that Rage that's ready
to be released is when he
brutalized and punched to death that fed
regard like yeah just seeing when he
goes into protective mode on people that
that mean something to him then I'm like
it for me it wasn't far-fetched yeah
when I watched that scene I'm like yeah
I could I could see this guy like
totally going Terminator John Wick on a
bunch of people in a hospital when it
comes to protecting those he loves guys
if you're still here and you haven't
left a like can you leave a like please
please we'd appreciate it and also if
you could possibly get a t-shirt shop
Zero edition
Shannon bear is only rumor to play uh
Michael thank you for the Super Chat
thank you Michael
they did not reveal who the actress is
for Abby is I think I think what
happened with Shannon Barry is is that
like there's been so much talk around
Shannon Barry yeah that and I think like
someone on the like or Neil druckman or
someone like followed her and so people
thought like this must be confirmation
but it's not I mean he follows me and
I'm not confirmed to be Owen so
it's true
Troy Baker follows me yeah we're trying
to out each other and send him dick pics
and then you follow me I thought we were
going to keep him in the DL you're
trying to get us demonetized sorry
Michael do you think Bella needs to bulk
up and see it needs to bulk up in
Seasons ahead I mean did you feel like
she was super I mean I felt like that
was more Abby in in part two I mean she
definitely should I mean get I mean I'm
not saying she's got a she's gotta get
more of an athletic build yeah
athletic not like bulky and buff like
that's not how I viewed Ellie I mean
Abby Abby's physicality is the
embodiment of Revenge yeah like when the
moment comes I will I'll be a golf club
yeah I'm Sarah Connor jacked but I'm I'm
using the golf club golf pill I've built
my body to swing the skull uh no I but
um but I think uh I definitely think
that yeah you she does need to
you know I don't know
Ram's not like out of shape or something
I think
that sounds right to me but like I
imagine like she's much more of like she
runs and probably does some push-ups or
some [__] I don't know
um yeah no and I agree like what Judith
is saying here is like it's less about
her muscle tone and more about seeing a
physical change yeah yeah I agree Nick
cages Abby yeah make it happen
hey Greg I like that
um
hold on a sec I think I lost my spot
here
or or I'm fully caught up I think I'm
fully caught up like I did it Andrew you
did it I'm a j I'm a j hold on let me
just confirm this
it's nice dude this is this this live
stream is really more for Andrew and I
to get other things off our chest that
we didn't get a chance to talk about
because like we said we had to be so
careful yeah and Greg got accused of
spoiling stuff just from a t-shirt like
that he was wearing like this this video
game cover was everywhere before I even
played The Last of Us from like that
yeah I'm like but the non-gamer Casual
is not gonna know that's L I mean I
don't know just
um can't win them all I guess let's go
has anyone seen Abby in the hospital I
have no idea like I'll be I'll be if
someone could provide an image I'd be
happy I would love to see it because
again Greg and I are the same two smart
gentlemen who missed the clicker at the
end of episode one when the lightning
struck up on that building so I'm not
saying it's not possible that Abby was
not there but I
remember seeing a shadow yeah or nor
have I seen any pictures online so if
anyone wants to send us something like
please like I'll take a look at it
Ryan Platts thank you Ryan Pleasant
thank you Ryan the golf club scene is
important because Ellie needs to watch
Joel get beaten to death and is unable
to help him like he has helped her yeah
no it is there is absolutely it's
important I should be a quick death yeah
oh of course not I mean but you
mentioned like
Abby's physicality and that this is
everything she's trained for so whether
it's a golf club or her just punching
and punching and punching and punching
and then like I don't know doing either
way I I'm gonna be okay either one like
because using her physicality against
Joel like that wouldn't bother me as
much but I get it the the Joan one is
very iconic I understand
or divisive depending on who you talk to
it's going to be a major gamble because
right now what what I think is happening
with um like the Joel death is is again
obviously such a big time he's the main
character in the first it's a bold ass
move that they did and a controversial
one and like gaming history it's one of
the most controversial ones
um but the
for a show it's risky as [__] like I
wonder what HBO is gonna react like
how is HBO going to respond to this I
mean because yeah you think you got to
think about this for a second they're
gonna give them more money to do the
next season because the show is such a
hit that's one of the biggest things
they see that Pedro Pascal is one of the
biggest draws ever yes they really let
Craig Mason and Neil druckman have so
much creative freedom they really let
them have it and then they got to tell
HBO you know we're going to kill off
Pedro like pretty like we're gonna we're
gonna kill them it's not gonna happen to
leave and then HBO is going to be like
well we're giving you all this money and
he's kind of like our big draw actor
here you know like the last of us that
this creates a good moral dilemma yeah
but no I mean it's it's like I can't
imagine like HBO being like I don't know
guys I know we got killed people all the
time but that's why I love your idea
when it comes to hey let's start off
with a young Abby let's let's get
invested in this character obviously we
got to get to the point of Revenge and
and get the plot you know started at
some point
I I would just say like do a lot of
flashback sequences like make it very
well known that you are going to have a
lot of flashback sequences with uh Pedro
Pascal's character of Joel uh because
that's gonna have a lot of you know
weight to it in terms of re-watchability
for people at least if they can see
flashbacks and okay hey you know what
I'm very angry that he was killed off
like this really upsets me
but I see that they're doing a lot of
flashbacks so I know I can still watch
them because I love that that scene
where they had the flashback with Tess
with Bill and Frank yeah such a great
addition like such a smart way to bring
Tess back
uh let's see here
uh epic games thanks for being here boom
City I agree adrenaline is a hell of a
drug it is
um that's what I take every time I come
on the Shelf yevin Badger hey Micaiah is
a friend of Michael Tessler well thank
you for being here friend of Michael
tesler
let me see here
yeah Ellie was not buff all right whoa
whoa whoa whoa lost the spot ever
everything got refreshed hold on a
second
it's going catching up the chapter extra
slow mode how will they make her look
taller I don't think she needs to get
taller
like planer High makes it I would say in
order to make her look taller she needs
to talk to uh Jack uh travin or Travis's
character Keanu Reeves in speed right
what's that line he says after uh Dennis
Hopper's head yeah but I'm taller I
don't know I don't know
I I just don't know Andrew
is that a line from Batman mask of the
Phantasm I just don't know
Ryan Platts thank you Ryan I don't know
if you saw this but they confirmed
they're doing multiple Seasons part two
and they're trying for a 20 24 25
release I did see that damn if we got
Last of Us season two in 2024 next year
that would feel rushed uh so you don't
think it's gonna be next year
I think it would be 2025 at the earliest
and then this [__] is hard to put
together
you know when they were sending out
screeners for this the VFX were nowhere
near done for most of the episodes
and you don't want to rush that like I
think we gotta like it's really slow
down and not rush that [__] honestly I
mean and and knowing what's in this
season I'm like no please don't rush
this please take your time yeah like I
really want them to take their time yeah
I'd rather I'd rather wait a couple of
years I'd rather wait two years and it's
interesting day and age we limited with
television isn't it where we can wait
that long for something whereas before
there was a time where like has to be
next European forget it yeah and uh but
I think for Last of Us season two like
as Jazz as I would be for it to come out
next year I'd also be like that was fast
um I'm kind of worried about this so
yeah I I really hope they don't um
I hope they don't do that well you
definitely run into that worry if you
come out next year with it and the
quality is not to the level of season
one or the video game then you come up
with saying like why didn't you guys
just wait a little bit longer but I can
definitely also on the flip side see HBO
Max like we've got a hit we've got such
a hit have it ready as soon as possible
to to Craig and Neil so yeah I just
don't think they should do it um Chad
Michael Simon thank you for the Super
Chat your first whatever
thank you Chad in game Abby's identity
was kept a mystery till her half
um yes yes you're right I could see
value in letting a television audience
know who she is from the beginning
that's the biggest change of I think I
think they have to make that change
because it would be it's it would be it
would be awesome if they did that it
would be awesome you know
um I remember when I was younger I saw
this Godfather thing that they did was
it was really cool because if you guys
haven't seen The Godfather spoiler alert
spoiler alert on a film from 1972. no I
mean it's not much of it I'm not going
to go into any details so they have the
Godfather part one
and then in Godfather Part Two they cut
back and forth between young Vito
Corleone have you seen Godfather of
course they have a young veto I don't
know he didn't know if Stephen young is
oh I think in comparison
and they have young Vito Corleone and
Corleone and then they have the the
actual sequel continuing from Godfather
one and there was this recut that they
did uh where they put everything in
Timeline order and then they've aired on
television it was pretty cool to watch
and I kind of and so with that kind of
mentality I'm think I'm thinking that's
why structurally they as cool as it
would be to do the game structure I feel
like they're just gonna cut back and
forth between Abby and Ellie absolutely
and I and I feel like you know you don't
want to lose view it's so different it's
like Neil druckman himself has said it
that it's kind of a cheat code to get
you invested in a character because
you're playing as them yeah you know so
you you get to be them it's easier to
get them into your perspective important
like their point of view
uh for the emotional storytelling
aspects where you're gonna have to do a
lot more work for [__] Abby on a show
because you're just an observer well if
you also start off you know the show
without a young Abby getting us invested
getting us to sympathize with this
character seeing Joel as the villain
through her eyes yeah it would it
wouldn't make sense to all right now
we're just going to focus only on Ellie
for you know only season two and then
we're gonna come back to Abby's
perspective from season I don't know I
just I don't feel like that would work
so I could totally see them just cutting
back and forth you know good for a good
episode focus on one character maybe the
other one or just cut back and forth in
episode to the two characters like Hey
we're on Seattle day one we're gonna
focus a good chunk on this character
come back to this character kind of
thing because you already know who this
character is we're not you know delving
into the possible mystery of a Revenge
hunt and you don't know like we're not
going to come back to this character so
yeah they're definitely gonna have to
change it up for sure from the story
structure that we got from part two no
doubt no doubt hey guys thank you so
much for being here again if you're
still here please leave a like if you
haven't done so already the rock is Abby
I can see it I will beat you with the
golf club hey uh Joel do you smell what
The Golf Club is cooking
um
you didn't like that Greg nope nope it
was it was it was mediocre guys it was
meteor guys you have no idea how hard it
is to make Greg laugh seriously it's
really hard I try even when I pay him a
hundred bucks to say hey You're gonna
laugh at my job he still doesn't
silly duck
I love Florence but that's a horrible
choice
I know but but I want she's I want Abby
to be like if they do catch Hollywood
hot if they do cast Florence Q I ask one
thing I want her to do her black widow
impersonate or uh accent when she when
she missed your Super Chat kg Gould what
are you talking about
oh oh we did Mr Super Chat we are sorry
kg you're right I'm gonna go find it I'm
gonna find it KJ I'm sorry KJ boom
you're right thank you KJ for informing
me and thank you for the thank you Jason
appreciate it thank you spores from the
game could have been it's your first one
thank you Sports from the game could
have been explained as only releasing in
dark damp environments with the gas mask
it gave us a great claustrophobic feel
what was can can you refresh what was
the reason behind it is that they felt
that if they did spores that it would
just be everywhere yeah that's going to
be everywhere and also too we just don't
want to have a large focus on not being
able to see what the actors are doing
it's the same thing happened with in
superhero moves when you have actors you
know covering their face with masks you
want to be able to see what the actors
are conveying in their facial
expressions and they didn't want to be
locked in a corner where like there's
going to be a lot of different places
because spores can spread everywhere so
we don't want these actors being
consumed to these masks and not being
able to see how they're emoting or their
facial expressions so I mean look it's
it's an iconic thing from the game I
would have loved to have seen it for
sure in here but I understand the
reasoning behind not doing it and again
if they would have done the actual you
know the the network the the quarter
steps network if they would have leaned
more on that like because after episode
two like Greg and I were completely
praising like what a great idea like you
are really there's nowhere to go you're
always trapped like with with uh
infected possibly coming after you so
I'm hoping that they season two like
again if they don't go to the sports
route which is fine let's lean a little
more on the network route of the quarter
steps and I just think that that that
goes a long way like
when you have additions that get rid of
things that are iconic from the game if
they're interesting additions like but
stick to that I agree with you Andrew
well I I wish they could find somewhere
and also it's also a big part of it's
also a big part of um of uh Joel like
seeing that Ellie is actually immune as
well but they they kind of made it
the bloaters
yeah yeah well also the shamblers too
kind of funny he's doing a live spoiler
cast with Neil druckman right now that's
way cooler than what we got going on way
cooler but don't go there guys
don't do that
ramoni that's how you say it or r or am
I
or Armani Armani Armani I think that
sounds right Armani
okay
all the ladies on the chat want to touch
Andrew's mustache oh Touch Away enjoy I
need to find a hold on I'm gonna go on
Twitter really quick and just see if
there's this photo of ad if someone has
to have if this if this is really here
it says Abby's trending in California
right now really
I mean it's obviously about her
person with pigtails is that a person
with pigtails
really this is this is what people think
looks like a person just
that's hard to tell on that picture
I really
not saying that campaign okay here's
another shot
oh I'm not saying it's not her but I'm
not I don't I I don't know maybe maybe
I'd say
[Music]
I could see it being her but on the flip
side it could just be a rant you know
there's a lot of different fi we know
like the whole group that comes after
but Abby's like a kid here yeah this is
that looks like an adult what people are
doing with Abby
I mean unless they really change it like
this looks like Abby who she is in the
game and that Abby from the game
wouldn't run away you know what I mean
that Abby from the game would be like
I'm gonna kill this guy
Abby kid Abby would not do it because
she's a skinny scrawny and this looks
like adult Abby so I don't I don't feel
like this is Abby but we also know again
this is just from the video game we know
in one of the flashback sequences in
part two to showing Abby in the hospital
that she did have a gun in her holster
so yeah knowing that again possibly like
her life is in danger and her father's
life is in danger seeing her run away I
don't know that's again she's not built
up and trained to where she's mentally
and physically where she's going to be
yet in part two
but having a gun like to her side and
seeing her run when her life is on the
line and her father's line is on I don't
know and
might just be there for an Easter I
don't know okay the media nights
apparently we skipped yours too hold on
I want to make sure
there we go boom thank you for letting
us know sorry sometimes it just goes a
little weird here
thank you media Knights do you guys
think they're gonna stick to the game
structure one season for Ellie then
Cliffhanger in the theater and then have
the next season before average
perspective we loved your reaction guys
thank you yeah we've touched on this um
and uh but no I mean I I that's too much
of a tall order like I said I really
feel like they're gonna be doing the
cutting back and forth like the
structure is such a such a meaningful
like it's such a shocking part
of like when you're first playing that
game
I remember because I didn't know that
that you're gonna be doing that I wasn't
prepared for
when you do encounter Abby and then we
cut to back and I'm like what the [__]
we gotta [__] play as her now like
that was such a [__] that was a bunch of
[__] to me the first time we did it
um and it just felt like it like like
took the momentum out of me like took
the wind out of me and like we should
come on
and uh I don't know if on especially for
a season three if that if that would be
something audiences would come back for
I just it's just it's so different it's
a completely different Association yeah
I'm just aiming to watch on a video game
that can work I just don't think in a TV
show especially with non-gamers and it's
not that they can accept it I just think
you
I just think Greg's presentation of
getting is showing a young ad being
getting her perspective and her point of
view on how she feels towards what Joel
did to her father getting people and at
the minimum to understand her motivation
will just go a much longer way than
cutting back and then you know seeing
her POV at this long after what she has
done to Joel so I I don't know I just I
I just don't see that story structure
from the game I just don't see it
working if they go that route personally
but that doesn't mean they can I mean
these guys have completely you know Neil
and Craig have proven that they can make
anything work at this point in terms but
I just think Greg's presentation makes a
whole lot of more sense in my mind for
story structure shop zero edition.com
thank you JP for showing your support
and hope down the chat here everybody JP
let us know which shirt you get
uh let me see here
Trenton
what if they make one of the nurses Abby
thoughts well I mean that'd be funny but
on the flip side it wouldn't make sense
that she just let like did nothing after
her dad got shot well you know I didn't
know this Laura Bailey actually played
one of the nurses in the game oh I
didn't know yes I thought it was just a
special Cameo of like let's put I mean
oh you're talking about from the first
game yeah right I did not actually know
that I did not know that I didn't know
that either until I think last night I
learned it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what
a crazy thing you go from playing a
nurse
and also you know who else she voiced
right in one of your favorite video
games Spider-Man 2018 she's at Mary Jane
Watson oh is she really
that's good but but that's good to know
but I guess this is technically the
second actor or actress in The Last of
Us to reprise their role like after
Merle tantridge the nurses back as the
nurse it's true that's true
um let's say here let's say here
trying to just get to my
okay trying to get to where our last
left off
come on
come on okay yeah we guys we gotta wrap
up in like 15 to 20 minutes so
we're off to next you're gonna see jabby
Coe sounds like a plan he's seen shabby
after this I'm seeing jabby are you
seeing jabby later I will never see
jabby again oh okay I'm sorry to hear
that if there is one negative thing
about part two it said it's a bit
stretched out but I think it's a good
story yeah no I think I think so like I
prefer part two over part one but I I
would also say that it's a bit like the
the gameplay is amazing and I think it
pops the first one I agree but then it
does get to a point where like it's a
little repetitive yeah because because
the game's so long and they're like we
run out of you you eventually run out of
variety on the situation no doubt I
understand no the for for me I I told I
agree with what you said the gameplay
outshines the first one but the first
one's still the gameplay is phenomenal
exactly but I don't know the storyline
and the way I I just for me the
storyline is like absolute perfection in
the first game and it's pretty damn good
in part two like in my mind there was no
way you were gonna top part one and I
know in your mind they did which is
great I love that uh but it doesn't it
does not top part one for me like also
remember part one is my second favorite
video game of all time so hard to top
that Billy verse thank you for the Super
Chat thank you favorite reaction Channel
especially for this series thank you
thank you Philly thank you just joining
in now although are you team Joel or
fireflies much love sad it's at an end
for now
um I think ultimately
ultimately I'm team Joel
um like while the second game softened
like makes you go especially when you
see Abby's Dad having the discussion and
having the utmost confidence
that if they were to like uh pull from
Ellie and they kill her and everything
that yeah they could actually produce a
vaccine as much as they they do that
what I'm
watching this as a kid like when I'm
watching this I'm like I would make the
same choices Joel I I would if I was
Joel I would be making the same Choice
yeah
um
obviously it is not the better long-term
choice and the better for Humanity
Choice like I understand that too uh but
in this particular case it is like well
yeah I mean if I was this guy I don't
think I would just be like especially
with the way the fireflies handle both
in game and in the show they're
incompetent they handle they're so cold
about the whole thing that you're like
you guys are behaving like villains so
yeah this is going to of course Joel's
not gonna like side with you one bit uh
or even consider your your um your
option because you guys are behaving
like villains yeah you know they they
don't behave they're not like told you
have to understand this is our one like
they're not trying to talk like any
there's not a shred of sympathy in it
and and they should have just let Ellie
have the choice honestly dang it you
just stole my point I was gonna make I
was gonna say I'm team give her the
choice but I am I am still team Joel
yeah I get it like the greater good was
possibly sacrifice and you know getting
the world back to where it used to be
but again if I put myself in Joel's
shoes like if that was my surrogate
daughter I would do the exact same thing
like after everything he's gone through
and everything they've been through he
was just not gonna let you know I mean
especially knowing that she didn't even
have the choice as well like he just was
not gonna lose another daughter not when
he had control and power like that and
he could control her fate he that was
just not happening he already felt the
world was a broken place even when it
wasn't infected and had the quarter
steps brain uh you know infection so
again losing a daughter and getting the
world back to where it used to be was
just not an option for Joel yeah so from
that perspective I'm totally team Joel
thousand percent
um Ryan Platts they age him up a lot
thank you Ryan thank you Ryan it's like
your third Super Chat they Asian him up
a lot from the game too seeing him even
older and unable to even put up a fight
against Abby would just be so sad
oh yeah
and then and also like Troy Baker's Joel
is like super buff whereas Pedro pascals
is
um he's pretty buff too I'm I mean he's
strong but he's got a bit of a belly
like a tiny tiny bit
he's not like he's not like Joel from
The Last of Us game buff
he's
Pedro Pascal's even admitted to it well
also too you know getting saw Pedro
Pasco on a wired interview admit to it
yeah oh okay so I'm not being in solemn
feel like I'm saying what he's talked
about oh well also to you know getting
shot in the leg with a shotgun you know
goes a long way with not being able to
put up much of a fight as well that's
gonna be brutal I forgot about that part
yeah and then they would they put a
tourniquin on his leg oh
yeah I don't I just don't think this is
Abby I I I I don't either but I mean I
don't know I think that's a Neil
druckman Craig Mason question like
they'll be the ones to verify but I
don't think it's her but
does Joel not shoot at this person
uh I mean he's pointing the gun in
picture three there so yeah I I don't
know
um
Skylar Hillman how do you think the
third game will ultimately thank you
Skyler by the way thank you thank you
Andrew for reminding me to think doing
the thing that I give John crap about
but I understand now when you're in this
position that sometimes you're just like
you gotta keep this livestream on track
I'm sorry
uh Skyler Hillman thank you for your
contribution I think the third game will
conclude Ellie gets her fingers back
yeah she gets her fingers back and they
resurrect Joel
Multiverse work they reanimate him back
to life um no I think that
I I personally would like it where they
do go like we need to they find a doctor
they hear of someone and like they bring
It full circle where they where Ellie
probably makes where Ellie can make the
ultimate sacrifice
I would totally be fine with that and
see that happening I mean she's had the
heroes Journey at this point and also
and all the trauma and she wanted her
life to have me I'd love to see her live
in Abby as well just teaming up to get
to that point as well that would be so
damn poetic like the man that took your
surrogate father for reasons of
understanding like even though you don't
want to work with her like it's for the
greater good so that would go such a
long way in her character Arc
I think that's a great call
um Neil we hope you're we hope you're
watching this set it up for game three
all right Andrew I'll play some catch up
here okay deleted EXO Ellie just thank
you deleted EXO [__]
thank you
Ellie just got taller and tatted not
buff what the [__] is everyone talking
about also excited to see what they do
with Tommy's kid in season two I want
season two late 2025. yes I would like
that too I think Tommy's kid will become
king of wakanda
um but yeah I know I mean Ellie got
taller but there there is more there is
more of like an athletic like uh on a
runner's body it's a like type of or a
bit more of a fighter like a bit of a
broader shoulders and stuff like there
there is there is more of a strength to
her for sure so I I don't
I think that's what people mean by that
there is more of a physicality
intimidation word you can see how this
person who is jacking up all those
people the wlf you can see how that
person can get away with doing it and
not only that I mean she's gonna be in
two one-on-one I mean at least from the
game she was in two one-on-one fights
with Abby and Abby and one of those
fights is at the peak of perfection when
it comes to physicality yeah so I mean
for her to even withstand any of those
blows she's got to be in some kind of
physical you know shape obviously in
Abby's second fight uh in Santa Barbara
she's lost all her muscle mass just from
dehydration from uh not being able to
eat food and being basically tortured
from the Rattlers so you know in terms
of Ellie's physicality at that point I
mean obviously it didn't matter as much
but definitely in one of those fights
she's got to have a little bit of a
physical peak again you don't have to go
the buffer out but yeah Jeremiah says
Walking Dead Or Last of Us which is
better well I haven't seen walking dead
so I gotta go with Last of Us I think
Walking Dead was cool and then I
completely quit the show I just made a
conscious Choice like I completely quit
it
um I don't know I mean it's kind of not
a fair comparison honestly but uh
zombies all right how about this uh what
What's the uh I am legend or the last of
us or you can't compare most of us okay
zombies and zombies I I will say though
I Am Legend had the best IMAX opening
scene to a movie that wasn't related to
that movie ever The Dark Knight baby oh
I should have left right after that I
put a link in the regular chat thank you
pandemic Jones I put a link in the
regular chat to where people think it is
Abby in the finale you might have to
command F my name to find it no I mean I
see the image like it's the same image
on on Twitter the same a couple of
images and so thank you for sending that
thank you but yeah I uh I don't think
this this is not Abby I don't think it's
Abby if it is nice Easter egg but I I
personally don't either but if it is
cool
it's just not in character with again I
understand she's not in physical peak
and mental condition because she doesn't
even realize what it's about to happen
to her dad but again in the video game
at least Abby still had a gun in her
holster at this point and I just knowing
Abby I just don't see her running is
Daphne Keane is Abby not a bad call
no I'd be okay with that oh yeah the
Cobra Kai girl you know that would be a
good one Tori Tori that's not a bad pick
yeah because Cobra Kai's ending she was
gonna need another job Hayden Peyton
Reed
director Advantage yeah no Peyton uh
what's her what's her last name I said
Peyton and I go and write to read Peyton
uh a lot some starts with an L I think
whatever her name is uh yeah I could see
her I mean you know she's got Charisma
and she's fantastic as Tori and Cobra
Kai so I could definitely see her Ryan
Platts thank you Ryan 100 guarantee
Tommy's kid is going to be pivotal I
mean that's what he'll be like five I
mean yeah because what is it three or
four years later the game yeah right the
time Jump so uh but yeah his pivotal is
a three or four year old can be for sure
I mean it's definitely gonna have some
decisions that weigh on Tommy and like
that can possibly fracture the
relationship between Tommy and Maria
like hey I get where you're coming from
and wanting revenge for your brother but
you've got a son and a family and a wife
here like
so I mean from that perspective
definitely pivotal yeah yeah it's true I
was hoping to see more of the tendril
Network stuff be cool season two have
more of that yeah I agree Cameron
kandori Greg I sent you the photo of
Abby thank you Cameron I appreciate that
camera and thank you for the Super Chat
Cameron and thank you for looking out
buddy Josh Z thank you for the Super
Chat thank you Josh uh do you think
there is any chance Abby goes after
everyone around Joel's Revenge my logic
is that the true Revenge would be to
Target everyone else and leave Joel even
more broken that'll be an actually an
interesting way to to keep Pedro around
a little like I think you would still
have to kill off Joel but if they do
decide to
set up some other people in Jackson and
then those people are killed but you're
not going to feel as much of the as the
audience like you've got to get that
Revenge you're not really gonna feel it
as much but that would be an interesting
way to postpone Joe's yeah death scene
no from from the perspective of I want
more Pedro Pascal in present time
absolutely that's an interesting way of
going about it the only issue and
problem is Abby wants direct revenge on
the man directly responsible for
murdering her father so yeah I just
knowing Abby's character from part two I
don't see her I just want to torture
this man as much as possible not
physically but mentally by hurting
people around him like she it was very
again interesting idea but it was made
very clearly in part two in the video
game that
uh we are not like she had a chance to
kill out uh Ellie she had a chance to
kill Tommy in the scene where she kills
Joel yeah she made it very clear we're
not here to kill them and Owen obviously
was a helping Hannah but we were not
here to kill them we were just here for
Joel and that's it so but interesting
perspective to keep Pedro Pascal in the
present time longer for sure thank you
Josh appreciate it thank you Josh hey um
thank you to everyone's contributed for
super chats I'm gonna turn off the Super
Chat thank you all thank you but I'm
going but we're gonna wrap up the ones
that we currently have I got to get
Andrew out of here is that thing that
koi does where he drags out his time
here oh sorry guys I'm answers every
question would so much is it so much
care and consideration I should just say
yes you gotta you gotta pull other live
stream methods we're just like yeah no
whatever thanks moving on okay in the
future I will that's how that's how most
people live streaming and got to be more
like that so in the future I will do
what women do on dates with me one word
and answers my my bad
Peyton List that's I don't feel sorry
for you Peyton List and I've seen the
woman you go on dates with that's her
name Peyton List
yeah
we were gonna get there yeah
uh don't worry we'll still read your
comment Chad Michael Simon thank you so
much a challenge with cutting between
the two halves is Abby's story has
nothing to do with Ellie until the end
of her day three audiences might be
confused
that is true it is kind of like
I don't know it could be still building
up to it because it is sort of like Abby
just goes like what happened they're all
dead huh like by the time at by the time
Abby goes to find Ellie
I mean yeah it does have nothing to do
but the whole the whole thing was I mean
it's it's a journey about like what am I
actually here to fight for when it comes
to fighting the seraphites like
everything I'm let because Abby is so
hell-bent on killing seraphite she's so
believing into the philosophy that Isaac
and the wlf have infused upon her and
just like her experiences with Lev and
Yar which are so damn deep and important
like give her a different perspective
kind of like with a little bit with how
Ellie felt towards like even in the show
like she was being trained by Yeah by uh
fedra and to hate fireflies and like no
now she wants to go to the fireflies hey
like I wanna like I need you to help me
produce a vaccine of my blood or my
brain whatever like kind of thing
Ellie's going down the Abbey path both
like literally and metaphorically she's
going down the Abbey path
and while she's going down that path
Abby's going down a very different path
that is causing her to not be the person
who would who would have killed Joel you
know and um so I do think actually
cutting back and forth would be would
would still work as granted they're two
very different plot lines yeah but I
still think it would work and last point
I want to make what I'd love to when we
are cutting to Abby what even before day
three we see that she doesn't get the
satisfa like seeing her in days one and
two shouldn't she be so happy she got
the man that killed her death
but like revenge is a Fickle thing like
it did like it doesn't it doesn't drive
her to a place like I still feel like I
still feel empty and hollow inside and
like and I and I got the guy who killed
my dad like I thought that was a very
interesting perspective that they that
they laid in the game was like okay yeah
this isn't pertinent story-wise but at
least like character driven wise like
this is damn deep in my opinion the
panda thank you thank you I hope you
guys are going to do a combo reaction
with game crew and non-game crew for
finale and there's time between Last of
Us one and two maybe they could fill in
the Time of the Season Two and Three
then Joel dies in season four they're
not gonna post everyone too much wishful
thinking here people too many people are
wishing they just wait till he pulled it
off hold it off it's gonna be soaked
it's like when you have a breakup coming
around the corner and just keep
postponing it when you know this
relationship's gonna end yeah you guys
be willing to rip that Band-Aid off it's
gonna be damn controversial when it
happens which is why again I think on
the route that you've mentioned earlier
it's not gonna it's not gonna soften the
blow of what happens but at least we
will have a perspective and a
motivational understanding of where Abby
is coming from
it's still going to be damn divisive but
at least again I think that is the
smarter route to go on yeah
no I'm not gonna do a video with John
The Last of Us
he had borrowed my game for years he
could have played it the first one yeah
years
but no he doesn't care about you guys as
much as I do I played for you guys
uh don't forget KJ KJ Peyton List from
Cobra Kai could play Abby thank you KJ
thank you KJ appreciate it thank you and
you stole that from me earlier I'm sorry
KJ my my apologies that was you I give
you credit perretta get I really don't
like the idea thank you for Renegade I
really don't like the idea of empathizer
with Abby before she kills Joel the
whole point is to let go of your anger
see things from a different perspective
after you already hate her again that's
something that I think you can that
totally makes sense when you're being
the one in control and you like the
thing with the Last of Us games is
whoever you are playing as you do not
break that perspective you just plain
and simple do not take like the show of
season one you break the perspective all
the time from Joel and Ellie like you
cut around in different characters and
you go into their perspective like
scenes where Joel and Ellie are not
around you are in you you are getting to
see who they are
that is it's different but when you're
when you are the one being the person it
is easier and then going through these
like experiences as that person
controlling them then you have an
opportunity and even then for a lot of
people they were not able to achieve
that different perspective even though
they got to play as Abby they a lot of
people were not able to achieve that and
for a show where you got to have people
tune in in weekly yeah where they are
going to be taking their time to cut
around other people's perspectives and
break from just locking in the alley or
just solely locking into Abby
I feel like you're gonna have to you're
gonna have to mix up the structure
personally absolutely
hold on Andrew
hold on just wait don't yell at me
Andrew
Abby versus LA fight in the theater is
going to be rough it's gonna be awesome
I can't wait for it I love that that
that scene in the game or that fight
because you are controlling uh Abby I
believe I know a lot of people I've seen
some uh YouTube stuff uh gameplay wise
people some people hate Abby so much
that even though they're controlling
Abby I've seen two different things one
they keep jumping off cliffs and stuff
to die yeah or they let Ellie just win
that fight like no no kill me
uh yeah no Ellie's scary in that fight
uh JP oh yeah no she actually is she
feels a little bit like David in yeah
yeah she's terrifying too many shirts
also Andrew you've been great uh JP well
thank you first for your contribution I
know Greg forgot to say thank thank you
so much JP and also for your comment I
appreciate JP you're great thank you
he's uh JP's amazing
season two is going to be if multiple
it's got a lot of repeat questions here
someone someone just I saw in the chat
someone said where is John and Tara's
reaction well like uh for the last eight
weeks it comes on Tuesday Tuesday
Mornings it will be here tomorrow so and
I will be tuning in first thing right
when it pops up on my YouTube feed they
have been great love watching them I
also find it's such an interesting
perspective from people who have not you
know played the game or not as in not
saying not invested in the characters
obviously they are but not like have any
expectations so it's got to be this way
I'm going to compare this and compare
that I just find like when Greg told me
what he was thinking like a month and a
half two months before like we started
like that's actually a fascinating idea
not for the fact that I actually like
want to do this reaction with you but
like Greg and earthquake John and Tara's
reaction like getting a non-gamer's
perspective like that's actually
interesting like just seeing like the
differences between us because Greg and
I are obviously we're so invested in
this world before the show even starts
so getting to see John and Tara's real
I've loved every second of it like it's
interesting you know to seeing the
contrast between us
yeah yeah great idea Greg is basically
what I said and that's soliloquy
and then you wonder how you don't get
out of here on time Andrew it's my fault
with you talking about my great ideas
and John and Terrace I'll tell jabby you
wouldn't stop talking even though he's
probably watching us yeah he probably is
I need to live stream like that Elias
how are you excited already Elias thank
you so much Elias thank you how excited
are you to see Sarah fights in season
two I hope they're terrifying I mean
yeah uh I'm excited to see them I
thought though it brought a different uh
and interesting perspective just having
this religious cult and just seeing the
war waged between you know the uh the
wlf the wolves and also the Sarah fights
and like how Isaac just seeks control of
this entire area so the only good people
are the people in Jacksonville that's
the only good people are the people in
Jackson
but yeah it's just so funny like they
all suck they're all terrible
um yeah the serif fights at action it
will bring a different a different side
to it for sure I I think like the
production on that and the kind of
choreography the brutality like that
could be some real heavy-handed Gore
with those guys oh yeah
yeah that's disturbing they could even
go racist with it if they wanted to
think they really can
um
the end does not justify the means
true Andrew Croft why'd you redact your
message well thank you when is Jonathan
John Terry's reaction I'm excited is
that why you redacted your message Jay
tomorrow hello love this channel thank
you Andrew by the way thank you Jay
Chewbacca I don't think Pedro assigned
to me Ned Stark Pedro's died in so many
different things he would totally be
willing to die
Pedro is so funny I'm obsessed with his
interviews he was just on hot ones
recently he's amazing
um every interview I've seen in the guy
he is hilarious one of the best SNL
scratch uh hosts I think we've ever had
honestly I gotta watch that he's so
funny he's like such a funny he like
I've only seen him in this like gravitas
work yeah and then I see him in
interviews and stuff like oh my God he's
like a really loose guy there was this
interview because uh he was in Buffy the
Vampire Slayer with Sarah Michelle
Gellar and Sarah Michelle Geller posted
a picture of them from Buffy and the
interviewer just really quick the
interviewer asked do you do you showed
him the pictures like oh my God that's
great and then said do you remember this
like I remember everything like we'd
have ice cream at midnight she'd invite
me to her trailer and she was so nice to
me always would give me like pointers
and stuff about my acting and stuff like
of course I remember everything like I'm
like so down to earth and so humble I
love it well it's also really honest
about his insecure like I think that's
the thing about why people love Pedro
Pascal too is because
as much as he plays like these tougher
more brooding characters and stuff and
he's amazing in these roles
when you see that oh he's actually also
like a really loose hilarious guy like
he's he's quite opposite from a lot of
the characters he plays yes in a way
that is
exceptionally Charming I think that it
makes you more uh attached to like oh
Petra he's a goofy guy he's goofy that's
the thing he's really goofy he's a
terrific actor Nick
what would you guys think of season two
being an original story outside of the
game story I'm just hoping for a little
more Papi Pedro love from Germany I mean
that's what everyone wants but it's not
gonna happen yeah it's not gonna happen
yeah I mean they're not gonna again
there's things I mean Neil and Craig
have said hey if it deviates from the
story and it improves it we will do it
but I know where you're getting at it's
it's gonna happen whether whether we
wanted to or not like
Jill's dying it's just it's gonna happen
and they're not gonna deviate
too far from from a lot of the things
that happen in the story so I I just
don't see that happening but if they did
totally deviate and do a whole original
story if it was as impactful and really
good as season one and and even better
than what happens in part two I mean go
go for it I mean I'm gonna watch either
way so
um but I just don't see them I mean when
you get the groundwork and they
there was too many things that they they
put in place into me foreshadowing
things to have me believe that they are
going to go a whole original route and
deviate totally different from part two
well said Andrew Gordon Ryan Platts
thank you Ryan thank you Ryan what if
Abby kills both Tommy and Joel and Ellie
has to watch over his kid
dude that would suck now you can't kill
Tommy well I mean you're saying Ellie
has to watch over the kid but I mean
Maria's still around so I guess Ellie
would be kind of more like a
is like I can't watch over my kid
it's too much reminds me too much of
Tommy no I I think I think they're gonna
expand on Tommy's screen time definitely
we're gonna see a lot more of that
Adventure he had that was not feat that
that was all happening off screen yeah
that is really important in last of us
too
um and and I I do think that will
ultimately
um
I don't think I don't think Abby will be
killing off Tommy I really hope really
be upsetting yeah I know I I would be
upset I'd be like bunch of [__] I
did like uh that sequence where you're
playing as Abby and Tommy's trying to
sniper rifle you like that is a tough
and very tense sequence
would be cool if they kept that one in
there for sure yeah but I agree with you
they're going to expand Tommy's role and
screen time in this for sure
Ramon Brown who do you think will win
the fight Joel Rick Grimes I think live
action Joe will lose Rick Grimes but I
think video game Joel would beat Rick
Grimes Dave Lopez thank you your final
super chat today thank you Dave do you
guys think season two will be much
longer yes yes I feel like they'll get
at least one more episode I think it'll
be 10 episodes
it's you got to do at least 20 episodes
if you're gonna adapt season two so I
think season two I mean uh the two
seasons of this game so two seasons of
ten episodes two seasons ten episodes
yeah I feel like I feel like they can
they can manage that oh yeah I could
yeah I could see that but here serious
tone I know you you like to be sarcastic
Craig right I've been really serious for
a lot of this serious I don't know where
where do you truly like where do you
truly see the season in your mind ending
season two like to live leave for a
cliff it because obviously there's no
Cliffhanger to you just play the whole
game uh when you're playing part two
where could you be satisfied in your
mind where like this is a good place to
stop it right here before we continue to
season three
um I think it's when uh
uh when Abby discovers oh if they're if
they decided to like the ideal scenario
I I Envision yes yes the way you
envision yes is if they are cutting back
and forth between the two-story lines
is then you can
um
it would I wouldn't end it when when
Abby gets to the theater
I would end it when Abby discovers Owen
is dead
yeah
I could I could see that you know what I
mean because then you could expand upon
a lot of like the Santa Barbara stuff
and the Rattlers too because that
becomes one giant epilogue at the farm
and and then Abby and Santa Barbara like
that's it's just it's it's a really just
a big epilogue and I think you can ex
really expand on that [__] and and then
you're also drastically changing
locations from where your focus is
because everything's in Seattle in there
and then season three would be like the
start of the farm and then Santa Barbara
but you definitely want to see by season
by the end of season two you want to see
that massive battle between the wlf and
the seraphites right by the end of
season two that would be cool yeah so oh
yeah when they're running through it
yeah that's great yeah with uh Levin
Abby yeah that's where Abby loses all
her weapons yeah yes yeah that would be
cool
but knowing the show it'll probably be
like five minutes long right yeah the
whole sequence can that whole two-hour
sequence condensed to five minutes
you know it'll be like five Sarah fights
that just show up
um
I don't know that might even be too too
short then huh I think that's a great
ending spot yeah but I feel like you
would need like 12 to 13 episodes
instead of 10. if you were to do like I
think you could do like it's it's cables
so sometimes you don't need the exact
same number of episodes right so like
even stranger things when full
experimental this time where they had
like a few episodes and their part two
was like
the part two had like a two and a half
hour
finale episode in an hour and a half
prior to that you know and then you
waited forever for that so you you can
do something like that if they want it
as well where you do have season two
that's like 12 to 13 episodes and I
think that would be a great ending spot
not put it up that way that way your
season three can start off with a bang
where Abby goes to the theater like that
would be that would hook you in yeah
yeah I could see them but it ends with
like Abby knows and now she's gonna go
after Ellie yeah yeah
um I think that would be cool so that's
just my opinion though all right guys
well
we are done for today sorry fantastic
today I'm really tired
um but here we are
I I enjoyed that we were able to um
uh I'm enjoyed that we were able to
the the super chats are done right now
how do I remove this I'm losing my brain
power here and people
oh no wrong button wrong button
run go away
it won't go away
um
wait aha figure it out Andrew coming
closer to me Andrew
someone says oh and Andrew is handsome
and hot I'd love to hear that thank you
I appreciate it guys I'm here with
Andrew today I'm glad that we got to do
this journey yes glad we got to talk
about everything that we weren't able to
really talk about in our videos
um but I want to thank everyone who
joined us on this journey thank you and
oh yeah also by the way Bella was called
belly by Pedro Pascal yeah I again I
invented I I didn't but credit for
something that was not yours to be fair
to be fair I didn't watch any interviews
with Pedro Pascal to be fair but I'm
happy to give full credit because he's
one of my favorite actors anyway so
Pedro you get full credit I I guess I
took something I didn't hear from you so
my bad jackass yeah
but thank you guys for being here and I
I appreciate
um my Bros here
jabby's here he's gonna die
but yeah but I appreciate uh I
appreciate everyone for for um the
support over the past few weeks and
you know some people wonder how we got
these out fast it was a lot of fun
editing I won't reveal my secrets but it
was a lot of fun editing
it was uh it was a lot of fun putting
the thumbnails together it was quite a
journey so shout out to people really
quick here Christian thank you General
Grievous Seattle k-o Dave Lopez pandemic
Jones Rogue Persephone Andrew Gordon
you've you've been badger
and Abby the nerdy wave and guys
um keep a lookout for John and Tara's
reaction can't wait Tara's done
something special for you guys you will
see what it is and much love and we will
see you other things coming up here
this uh this week that I hope you guys
do enjoy all right I love you guys I'm
gonna end this stream right now much
love enjoy all the additional things
we've got to offer and leave a like on
this video and don't forget sure yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah not a not a bad call Andrew get a